Wow.
We Ladies and gentlemen.
That's right.
We're back.
And this episode is brought to you by Ting Ting is the official cell phone of
this podcast.
Did you and his pants?
Um,
I like that.
Can you show that Caesar when it's taught charging?
This is my,
uh,
my new phone.
When it charges,
it has this little thing that comes up from the charge or that looks like a lava
lamp.
Cool.
I'm 12,
by the way.
I'm fucking child.
But uh,
this,
uh,
this is uh,
the official podcast sponsor phone company and Tang has,
uh,
sent me this one where I really liked is the Samsung galaxy s five.
And with Ting is,
uh,
is a cell phone company that uses a sprint backbone way.
They do it is they rent time on sprint and then they do it by their rules and by
their rules means no contracts,
no early termination fees and a very unique way they charge you.
The way they charge you is like,
it used to be like if you had x amount of permits per month,
if you went under that you didn't get any money back.
But if you went over that,
you got some sort of overage fee that you were a,
you were hit with and it was usually more money for those minutes and it was for
your previous minutes,
which doesn't totally make sense.
Right?
Well,
the weights Tim decided to do it was just you pay for whatever you use,
which I think is what everyone's going to do eventually.
I mean we,
we've talked about this ad nauseum on the podcast,
but the best comparison I can make is what it used to be like back in the day
when you used to have what they used to call long distance fees.
He used to call you when I lived in New York and a,
I would call someone that lived in Boston.
I used to have to pay long distance.
It wasn't a local call,
like if you want to call someone in California would cost you more.
It sounds so stupid today,
but back then that was with regular phones and fucking,
God forbid if you called long distance on your cell phone back then,
good Lord.
It was brutal.
Was some,
it was so expensive that sometimes you didn't even have enough money to call
somebody and you'd have to call,
collect and collect calling cards where one of the biggest advertisements in the
rural,
everyone
my mother made me send a letter because she didn't want to pay for long
distance.
That's crazy.
It was in shame cause my shoot belling is show bad.
It was super expensive.
Um,
well that's the best analogy that I can make and I think that the way tings
doing it eventually,
that's how all mobile companies are going to do it.
Uh,
Tang,
when you want to cancel,
you just cancel.
You own your phone.
If you buy your phone from Tang,
they activate it,
you own it.
And you can get like,
if you're a Weirdo when you're like fucking flip phones,
even have those,
they have the Samsung m 400.
A lot of people are going retro.
Brian,
a lot of people are,
they're going with two phones.
They're going with a phone like this,
like the Samsung Galaxy s five for like their Internet shit,
their smart phones for their like email and then they're going flip phone for
calling.
Just call me bitch.
Stop playing games.
Only call me
Dana white buys them in boxes.
Old refurbished.
Flip phones.
And didn't you just post something the other day about somebody who only uses
like the founders?
Yes,
I did.
Yeah.
Some a guy who's a tech security expert,
he won't use anything but a pager.
Fucking Weirdo.
Well they can get in touch with him and then he has to remembers people's
numbers and then he has to go and buy like a,
a fucking dumper phone.
When I was little phones you buy from like seven 11 he buys one of those calls,
you burns it and that's it and moves on to the next number.
But using cell phone towers and triangles and stuff like that,
you'd still be able to find out where he is using the page,
right?
Oh No,
no,
no page is a different animal.
It's a different animal and it does.
Now the observer transmit like that?
No,
no,
no pager doesn't have gps pages missing a lot of stuff that they need.
Apparently this is obviously I'm talking about my ass.
I don't know Jack Shit,
but according to this security expert,
I think that was a reason why he went with a pager and let's find out.
Let's,
let's go ahead
because I know that that that pagers like I guess it sends out a signal going,
hey,
call this phone number.
Uh Huh.
And then I guess there's nothing in the pager that says eight received it.
Maybe.
But I think I remember pagers having a,
a receipt,
no,
I don't remember if she had a whole page or business what's going to go out and
close everything.
But they knew the one guy was still using it so right.
There's still,
everything is still on,
you know,
doctors don't,
they doctors still use pagers a lot.
Like if you always,
you're at the Er,
you always see their pay.
They still have pages.
Just maybe that's like in hospital maybe you can like go further than like cell
phone signals when they might not get you.
Does that make anything?
Alright.
No,
I can't find this article.
Uh,
so go,
go,
go get your Fox.
Um,
but the bottom,
the bottom line is the way ting has their cell phone service set up.
It's advantageous to most people.
98% of people would save money with Ting.
And if you go to rogan.ting.com you personally will save 25 bucks off of any of
their new awesome devices.
That's rogan.ting.com.
Like I said,
they have all of the,
like the high end android phones,
all the really cool ones.
And iPhone five.
Yeah,
they have iPhone fives.
You can buy them for 250 bucks.
It's pretty goddamn reasonable and not locked into some fucking contract.
Dope.
It's yours in the toilet and stick it up your ass.
Do you think all phones in like the next year are going to be waterproof?
Cause it seems like it.
Yeah.
That's the other thing I love about this Samsung,
this galaxy has four,
has a little tab on the bottom.
You closed the door and it's water resistant,
quote unquote meaning that if,
I guess if you like open the tab and throw in the water,
it's probably not so good,
but it's better than you know any regular phone.
It's not protecting you.
Yeah.
My friend just dropped hers in the toilet and I told her to suck the water out,
but she wouldn't do it.
So now her phone doesn't work.
Oh well that's what backups for me.
I don't have to suck toilet water.
If I had choice between sucking toilet water or paying to get my phone replaced,
I might have to go with pain to get my phone replaced over like some horrible
intestinal disorder that you get from poop.
I won't even drop my phone into soc toilet water.
I mean,
how could you just suck it out?
I just don't
because it's either like,
Hey,
do you,
do you want to just,
you know,
take some mouthwash later or blog 250 bucks.
Put it in rice.
That's what she did.
But I didn't have any rice.
I only had an old box of rice a Roni,
which should be the same thing,
right?
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
I didn't know if they like put some other shit in a box.
You had a box,
a box of Quaker oatmeal.
Maybe not.
Cause she doesn't say all right.
Maybe if you had fucking popsicles in a freezer,
the keyword is rice.
Yeah.
I don't know if there was like a spice on that shit or not.
I don't even know why.
There's definitely some spices on it.
Right.
I don't know what rights erroneous.
Really.
Cisco Tree.
That was like a big commercial where kids,
right.
So Rony the San Francisco treat it,
but why,
why just San Francisco?
I have no idea.
It doesn't make sense.
Charlie's in the logo,
I think,
but why?
Maybe they invented it there.
Yeah.
Invented it.
I mean,
what the fuck was rice a Roni?
Is that shit still around?
Just spicy rice,
right?
It's just yummy rice.
Which fuck.
Anyway,
rogan.st Com we're also brought to you by on it.
That's o.
N N.
I t.
Last commercial on it is a human optimization website.
Uh,
I've seen this commercial so many times.
It sounds like a robot thing coming out of my mouth.
But what we try to do with on it is to sell the very best strength and
conditioning equipment,
the very best supplements.
The very,
it's fun.
It's like protein supplements or cognitive function supplements like Alpha
brainer,
shroom tech,
all of it with references and research to whatever these individual supplements
are supposed to do,
like new mood,
the five HTP and l tryptofan supplement that actually boosts your serotonin.
There are certain products that you could take that vitamins,
certain supplements,
certain certain,
uh,
various nutrients that have been shown to have a direct effect on all various
aspects of your body.
It's strength and conditioning and endurance.
Um,
the way your brain functions and all of these studies that have been done are
all available for your,
your,
um,
discovery at [inaudible] dot com or you're a research if you're interested or
curious as to what all these things for about.
We also know that they're kind of,
these are controversial subjects saying things like performance enhancers for
your brain is a lot like saying big dick pills to some people,
they automatically,
their bullshit alarm goes off and it should.
But there are certain nutrients that are called nootropics and it's pretty much
scientifically proven that they have an effect on cognitive function.
It's been with double blind placebo tests,
um,
both on individual ingredients and unlike Alpha brain as a,
as a competent Tory,
a supplement all if you're interested or you're curious in,
in any way,
go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t and we also have a 100% money back
guarantee.
First 30 pills.
You have 90 days to just say,
I just didn't do shit for me.
You don't have to return the bottle.
You don't have to do anything.
You get your money back.
Our goal is to just establish a relationship with you where you were selling you
the very best products that can find that aid you,
whether it's for conditioning,
like kettle bells and battle ropes and all these different things that,
uh,
various tools that a lot of different people are using now for a strength and
conditioning on.
It has this new guy's name is John Wolf.
He's going to design all these courses for all these exercises,
for all these,
um,
different,
various,
uh,
strength and conditioning tools.
And he put me through this fucking ridiculous workout.
When I was in Austin,
it was all like hips.
Everything he made me do is my hips.
It's,
it's so weird.
Like my ass was hurting the weirdest way.
Like my thigh,
upper,
upper thighs and hips were hurting.
What can he do with baby making hips?
Cause I need to get rid of these.
Uh,
he can make your baby making him well,
look,
if you want to get rid of a man,
you just got to stop eating so much.
That's super simple.
Did it all right can thing is fucking dying.
Everybody's sitting here going,
I'm going to cry.
I mean,
I work out because this and that.
Look,
you fucking buffet molesters,
stop fucking eating and you won't gain weight.
Yeah.
And you'll lose weight.
But it's hard to lose weight because if you lose weight,
you have to suffer.
Is this,
the bottom line is you have to consume less calories in your body is burning.
There's all sorts of ways you can trick your body,
but the reality is you're going to want to eat more always.
So you're going to suffer in a sense because you're going to have that sense.
And you're like,
fuck,
I would love a burger right now.
God Damn it is this guy who will,
uh,
is that his real last name?
Yeah,
his real name.
I know.
It's funny,
the wolf pack,
he's a super,
super nice guy.
I put a picture of him up on my Instagram.
Um,
but uh,
the,
the workout we had was just so stupid,
ridiculous.
All these weird getups,
all these different things that we did from the hips.
And it makes me think like your hips are involved in so many different,
um,
things that you do athletically,
martial arts.
Uh,
obviously if you're throwing a ball or you know,
doing any sort of sport,
a lot of is you pushing off the ground and moving your hips.
It's incredible.
Like the,
the different workouts that people have devised in order to strengthen like
certain areas that really never get hit.
He's gotta be doing John,
we'll be doing a bunch of videos that'll be up and available at [inaudible] dot
com so if you buy like a Kettlebell or a steel Macy,
like now what do I do?
Well,
actually I've veto videos for them,
for each individual,
um,
different piece of equipment so you can check them out.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N n I t use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements tonight
and tomorrow are the last days that I'm prepping for my comedy central special
that I'm doing this weekend in Denver.
So tonight and tomorrow I'm at the Ice House in Pasadena with Tony Hinchcliffe.
It's almost sold out both nights.
I think there's only a few tickets left as of right now,
which is a three 15 today and the comedy store show you have a comic store
come Easter showed tonight.
We have a the first secret show that ever may try to hopefully do on a regular
basis.
Bill burrs going to be there.
Steve.
Stephen is easy allies.
Uh,
uh,
a whole bunch of secret surprise gas.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
It's only 10 bucks.
Funny,
funny,
like legit surprise guests.
We're going to go,
oh shit.
Like we can't tell you who they are for whatever various reasons,
right?
Or we just feel like being sneaky bitches.
What?
Okay.
Anyway.
Uh,
that's a desk.
Squad.
Dot.
TV for information.
Yeah.
Okay.
Squad on tour dates and a check that shit out.
You dirty fucks.
All right.
Rich Vos is here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
my longtime friend,
colleague,
comrade in arms,
give us some music.
Young Brian,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
Which boss?
We've known each other
for decades.
Sir,
take your time,
but a long time.
You're one of those guys,
I ran into you in the,
in the airport.
I get a giant smile on my face.
You know,
I remember us walking along,
walking along before we're doing a one night or in seaside with my ex wife.
I just,
when I was married to my ex wife and we're doing some shitty one nighter and uh,
talking taekwondo and karate and just,
I clicked with this guy right from the beginning.
You just shun comics,
you know,
like initially Keith raw machines line.
But it's so true.
There's great guy.
I love it.
They're back at a bus comics.
When they went to school,
they sat in the back of the bus,
you know what I mean?
They weren't the front of the bus fucking dudes.
Right.
And like,
you know,
like Rogan was a back of the bus walking guy,
and just back in the bus people,
you know,
look,
if I'm,
if I'm at a party and I'm one shot at a room is doctors,
lawyers and,
and,
and scientists and other side of the room is convict hookers.
And you know,
I'm going to go talk to the convicts and Hookers,
you know they're going to be more interested.
Give me more.
Interesting.
So you know that would comics too.
You could feel that with comics.
Who's more interesting,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
So shall,
and,
and then,
then we used to do danger fields together.
Those are great gigs.
Like in danger field.
He didn't prom shows did we?
Did you know how many prompts shows that we do at Dangerfield?
They would keep them going.
The prom shows,
hey,
would you like for a night?
But they wouldn't stop them.
It would just keep bringing people in and then we just keep rotating the comics.
So you'd be on stage and there was still be palm kids on the next show that they
kept rotating.
They haven't left yet,
you know,
and there's not like,
I had more material.
I just shame the shame bullshit I had the first time I was up there and they're
just rotten little kid that fucking have nowhere to go.
They're not going down the shore because whatever.
And I got to under a prom the whole time there.
Half of them are drunk.
They think you're going to get laid or want to get laid.
And I'm going to tell my horrible jokes,
which were horrible at that time.
Most likely too.
So it was just one big fucking horrible experience.
Yeah,
I remember those shows really well man.
They,
they've told you to do the same material so that you would kick the people out
so they would just get bored with you.
Go do the same material for the first show,
but you can't tell me what
to do.
Like if you hire me for a show,
you don't get to tell me.
I can't,
you know,
I can do different material on all four shows.
Cause if a guy had like rich Jenny rich Jenny was famous for,
he used to do the east side a comedy club and uh,
was it Huntington?
Huntington Long.
Yeah.
And Jenny like they would go,
he did four different hours on the weekend.
He did two shows on Friday,
two shows on Saturday.
He goes,
it was one of the guys who was working that think it was Brad Garrett.
I might be speaking out of school,
but I think it was Brad Garrett who was also,
I know he was a big fan of Jenny's.
Everybody was back then.
Jenny [inaudible] was the man.
He was the man.
A lot of folks don't know that.
He,
that guy doesn't get enough credit.
No,
not in the 80s he's probably the top 20 best comics ever.
Ever.
Yeah,
I agree.
100% I think Jenny back in those days was peaking and for whatever reason,
I don't think
much of the Americans like to have today.
Remember that for whatever reason,
I don't know why.
I wish I was booking.
When I first started comedy,
I booked a couple one nighters,
just sway.
I would get stage time.
I would host again other,
you know,
Jim Moshe had one nighters that stunk,
I let them do mine.
I would do those show you get work,
you know,
like back then it was no Selman all these one nighters in Jersey.
So I remember hiring a Mulrooney.
The headline Tahmo Rooney shall,
he came in,
he goes,
I'll bring my own opening act.
Saw Him there and the guy,
I go,
what's your name?
He goes,
ah,
Amish,
Jenny.
Uh,
I don't know if you know,
but I work catch a rising star I got while you're working here for 50 fucking
dollars.
Okay.
And he was bummed out that you didn't know who he was.
He always just starting.
We were all,
you know,
he was,
but he act like he already knew that he was great,
but he know,
but he was opening from old Rooney,
but he was like,
Jenny,
oh good.
You're getting 50 fucking nine.
Right.
Don't act like Jim Mulrooney.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
Uh,
he,
um,
he like Robin Williams committed suicide,
that,
that bombed a lot of folks out.
That bummed me on hardcore man.
He was brilliant when we,
when we worked on the Oscars for Chris,
when Chris was hosting the Oscars,
uh,
he was one of the writers.
I was one of them.
He was like,
you know,
a writing staff are down.
And Jenny was the most honest to Chris.
You know,
people would go,
wouldn't say go,
Nah,
you can't do that or no,
that won't work.
You know,
we would throw Chris Lines or you know,
this or dad or maybe do it.
But he would flat out and that,
and Chris respected the fact that this fucking dude knows what he's talking
about.
He has a great mind for comedy.
Richard,
Jenny can take any subject and turn it into a 10 minute pit.
Just,
you can take a bit about shopping for a car.
He had a bit about it.
He was in,
in Montreal at the comedy works.
It's during just for laughs during the comedy festival,
like a lot of comics will go around town and they do shows all over Montreal.
And Jimbo
was comedy works in Montreal is like maybe 90 seats,
right?
Maybe a hundred seats at the most.
And a rich,
Jenny did this fucking 10 minute bit on just buying a new car and it was
destroying.
It's like punchline after punchline,
Bam,
Bam.
Setting up the guy,
setting up,
uh,
you know how to sell the car to him and it was fucking genius.
And you like,
who the fuck writes a joke about buying a car?
You know what I mean?
It's like there's not much there.
Like if you thought,
if you,
you know,
he said,
hey,
uh,
I wrote a jug about buying a car.
I'd be like,
what'd you say?
Like what do you,
what are you saying?
10 minute chunk.
He was,
he was Hicks was like that too.
I worked with [inaudible] in Texas.
I mean this is,
I was getting high so 29 years ago,
30 you know?
Wow.
And something happened to him in seven 11 and he went on stage and ad Lib to
about it the next night for tea.
And I'm going,
I'll never be that funny as long as I fucking live.
I'll never be that.
Why am I doing this?
Do you ever see him when he was like 18
now
video of him,
he's a teenager,
I want to say you might have been earlier than 18 it might've actually been like
16 I think.
And he was really good.
Who was smooth?
He was wavering and I was like my first year at 21 he and he had been doing it
apparently even in this video,
we've been doing it
quite a while.
At 18 we were at catch a rising star in New York one night.
So Brenner goes on.
And this is,
I mean they love Brenner was fucking bread or at the time.
Yeah.
Cause he was a big act back then.
Big fucking act.
So ladies and John Deere Brenner kills the fucking audience,
goes nuts.
Okay.
So does his set and hex goes on after him Hicks opens up with,
you know,
I,
I was growing up and I used to watch comedy on TV and I'd watch Robert Klein and
David Brennan.
I'm thinking if these fucking guys can do with,
so can I,
that's his opening fucking joke.
He goes into that Nancy Reagan that anorexic can to sell.
So people are running out like there was a fire.
I mean,
he's just fucking cunt.
And I mean it's the comic and he gets off stage.
I swear to God,
he walked up to me.
He fuck what happened?
What went wrong?
Oh,
I don't know.
Maybe the anorexic content trashing the guy that they just fucking loved and he
was so fucking dark,
just dark,
just Wah.
You know what I mean?
It's just like if you listened to her,
now you're going to have,
that's all right.
But this is fucking 30 years ago,
this is 30 years ago,
this shit was fucking dark.
You know,
Jenny would take a bit,
he would take a premise like you say,
and you know,
it could,
he could turn it into 20 fucking minutes.
He would bring shit out of like,
how the fuck did he come up with that added that you're going,
what?
You know what I mean?
Uh,
but Hicks was so fucking dark and he just,
we,
we're in fucking Texas.
This is a true story.
So he,
his girlfriend just broke up with him.
He was going out with her forever.
So we're in a cab and he said to the cab driver,
I want to hooker in tech.
And we're in Lubbock in Lubbock.
It's a true story.
So,
oh man.
So that made me shiver.
Just thinking about it.
So,
so the cab drivers had,
okay,
I'll take you to one plate on and you go to their house.
So I was just going to wait in the cab like so he wants you to first house and
the lady opened the door and looked at him,
goes,
see a cops,
slammed the door excuse back in the car
dad,
but didn't,
it makes no sense,
Kevin.
I would chase him to another place.
She opens the door and goes,
you're too young.
Slams the door,
gets him to call.
He goes,
I can't get fucking hookers.
Me 10 minutes to the next night to brilliant fucking on hookers.
That won't fuck up
in local taxes.
Just fucking brilliant.
I'm going,
it's unbelievable how fucking good this guy is.
He,
he was going over a list of all the comics that were appearing at the comedy
connection and uh,
he's like,
let's see what's on the line up here.
He Goes,
Oh look,
carrot tops coming.
And he goes,
that's for folks who think I like Galler boot Gallagher.
I fucked it up.
Ready?
He goes,
I like Gallagher,
but he's too heady.
Who's been way better?
If I didn't stumble,
God damn mother fucker.
That's all right.
Yeah,
we got we,
but you know what I'm saying?
But I ruined a great joke from a great guy that's dead,
so I'm extra stupid for doing that.
But uh,
yeah,
he,
he was,
uh,
at the Nick's comedy stop and me and a Simmons and I think McGuire was there
too.
We're in the back of the room and there was maybe 10 other comics that have come
in to see him and he went on after this guy,
uh,
Larry Norton comic on a Harley and Larry Norton is very nice guy,
but he does his bit that he closed with about cartoon characters smoking pot.
Okay.
So he does a spit.
It's destroying and Hicks goes on stage.
And I mean,
from the moment he went on stage,
it was just a slow progression of people getting up and moving and getting up
and leaving,
getting up and leaving.
And there's a one point time where he's doing this bit about Satan fucking John
Davidson in the ass.
You remember John Davidson from,
that's incredible that that was after the anorexic con that he did
and he does.
He does the,
the John Davidson shitting out today was Oprah Winfrey.
It was different people on different days.
Some days it was Morton Downey Jr,
you know antichrist.
Yeah.
And he's,
he's like hovering over this hopeful like going,
ah,
I mean for minutes it,
it was so uncomfortable.
I just got to turn this fucking thing off.
It was so uncomfortable and funny.
Like comics are going,
this is the funniest thing about comics.
Loved it.
That's what was going to say.
The people were getting up and leaving in droves,
but at the end of the show there was maybe 50 people.
The audience that we're laughing and all the comics and the 200 plus people that
had left,
you know,
that we're gone missed out on some really ridiculous shit.
It was really funny.
He's shitting making that shitting sound for minutes and he looks up and he
goes,
yeah,
it's generally Claire's a room.
It didn't seem to bother him at all and that's what really I was really
impressed with.
I'm like,
this guy is eating it and the clearing the room and he's just sticking to his
guns.
Do you know what that thing that guys do when you feel someone when they're
bombing,
when they start panicking,
they start rushing and which doesn't work.
It's like the opposite because it lets people know that you're in a panic,
you know?
He knew he had none of that.
I mean,
he had that,
I guess that's,
uh,
that's how it is.
And just kept going.
I mean,
there was no,
no,
like,
don't anxiety to his performance at all.
Well,
because in his head,
the people that are staying in love it and that's,
he's working through,
that's his crowd.
He's going,
he knew
he was smarter than he knew his audience to build a,
you know,
that's what you're going to do.
He never fucking broke CAG bro.
He was,
and B got his fan base and he weeded out the fucking,
you know,
did I ever tell you that I had a conversation with Jay Leno about him?
No,
this was,
um,
I did the tonight show and the first time I did the tonight show,
the one thing that I really wanted to know,
I really wanted to meet Jay Leno cause uh,
I just,
uh,
from back in the 1970s and 1980s for folks who don't know,
Jay Leno was a very respected comedian.
Jay Leno was like,
he was a killer.
He was a really good young comic.
He's do spots on Letterman.
He was very edgy.
He was,
uh,
he was not the Jay Leno that everybody associates with being like this,
a middle America,
super sweet,
friendly host of the tonight show.
So I always wanted to meet him because I just had to respect as a standup and
two,
because I wanted to know what the fuck was the Hicks thing because Hixon him had
this crazy issue where he exited this whole bit about Jay Leno having Joey
Lawrence on his show.
And Joey Lawrence.
Hey,
thank yeah,
I think you got a girlfriend,
a you dating anybody who's well,
no,
maybe.
Huh?
And he goes,
and then j reaches into his drawer and pulls out a fucking Uzi and sticks it in
his mouth and blows his brains out.
And it,
it sprays out the NBC peacock on the wall because he's a company man to the
bitter end.
And He's,
he's screaming before he puts the gun in his mouth.
I used to be a fucking comic.
I used to have a fun
and then the brain spray out the,
and Ah,
I had asked him,
so I asked Jay,
I said,
what was that about man?
You know,
did you guys have an argument?
Did he,
he just didn't like us.
And he goes,
you know,
Hick fans,
this thing,
you know,
he might,
you want to,
don't.
Uh,
but he wanted to do finish cramp and,
uh,
you know,
he didn't want to work for everybody.
I like to do stuff for everybody.
He knows and that's not what he wanted.
And like,
wow,
that's an interesting way of putting it.
But I mean,
it's true,
I guess from Jay's point of view,
but,
uh,
you know,
there was a funny bit,
sorry,
blushing.
That's fucking brilliant.
He goes,
he takes out the clip and reloads.
It's tricky.
Think about it being a water fountain,
Slick,
a spraying water fountain,
a blood.
Oh,
that's where my bottom,
I hit my
bottom and Bosch pretty much where I used to.
I mean I stuck in comedy,
but somehow I got work in Boston and my dream was Nick's.
I mean,
I get one nighters,
I and I fucking buy coke from the coke deal.
FDR who
he was and stay at the,
at the Milner hotel behind the comedy canet where hookers and drug yet.
And so I'm working,
I'm doing a bunch of one nighters,
uh,
normal Foa and shit,
bring in Westfield mass.
It,
all those gigs was make crazy 52 elm to 52 while now,
what's the name of Klutz?
I said,
I'm coming up here for six days.
I'm not doing any drugs.
Right?
So I did like four or five days.
I had money,
you know,
for me back then I probably had three or 400 bucks,
which was a lot of fucking money or 500 bucks,
you know,
this is so then I do an a one night or and worst store at plums someplace called
plums in Worcester,
mass.
And the waitress after the show,
I was doing bits about coke on stage and she goes,
oh,
I liked those bits.
I go,
do you do coach?
He goes,
yeah,
I go,
do you know where we can get any?
He goes,
I'll make some calls.
And she was fucking smoking hot so she couldn't get any coke in Boston area or
wherever.
Worcester,
Worcester.
Should I say,
I know where we can get some common me.
And we got in a car and we drove back to New York.
Oh my God.
And I went to Spanish Harlem.
I bought maybe $300 worth of freebase crack.
We got a hotel and smoked it all night.
I fucked her all night and smoked it.
Just fucking,
I mean I'm smoking crack fucking her right.
And Saturday night and we wake up and she goes,
oh,
I gotta get back.
I'm now 40 minutes from my house.
Oh,
but I still have to Sunday night to do in Boston.
Oh I have to drive all the way back to Boston now.
Fucking
we're like no money.
I got enough.
20 bucks may be some cigarettes were driving up.
She goes,
I got to get high.
Can we get,
what can we get heroin,
anything.
So now we pull into,
we pull into fucking somewhere,
Dan Barry and buy heroin.
I think we got ripped off because it wasn't no good.
Then we're driving back my nose,
blood starts just pouring on my nose.
I give my shirt and I just put the shirt up and I'm bleeding from my fucking
nose.
I go to Boston,
I do the Sunday go home Monday and I go into Rehab on Tuesday.
I was fucking with my last run.
But the day before Rehab,
no,
I went in Wednesday cause I called this booker and in,
in New York and go,
I need a one night or tonight because I'm going to rehab tomorrow.
I want to get high one last time.
So he gave me this place,
BF patties.
I got 60 bucks,
drove to New York porch,
cigarettes,
tolls,
what?
Four vials to crack.
Smoked him to sign up.
And then I went to Rehab.
So it was,
it was Boston and then that Wednesday fucking rehab.
Do you ever do a normal foes gig?
Jay's and Pittsfield?
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
But I know one of the full Mark Ross showery Hirsch,
Sherry,
Sherry Hirsch hooked me up.
She hooked me up with a lot of great shows,
but the best comics came out of fucking boy.
I mean fucking uh,
Depalo Kenny.
I mean,
before Kenny Rogers,
[inaudible] fucking gods.
Gavin Gavin was fucking machine a monster.
I'm machine.
I really wish that somebody had filmed him and high rez when he was in his
prime.
I use it as prime.
Here's one of the best ever.
Yeah.
Well,
the best ever Sweeney it Chandler murderer.
If you lived in that area,
Sweeney Todd,
you had to live in that area though.
But if you lived in that area,
he's a murderer.
Couldn't Kevin Knox murderer?
These were all fucking kill.
I mean,
Steven Wright works from near Kevin.
Mike Donovan Donovan's on the murderer.
Kevin Meeney used to fucking murder.
Okay.
Uh,
all of them.
Kenny Kenny Rogers,
we went up.
Fantastic comments.
Just,
just a bunch of powerhouse.
Yeah.
And so polished.
Those are the things you would,
you would never expect,
guys that you never heard to be so polished.
And when Lenny,
Lenny Clarke,
yeah,
Lenny Clarke.
I worked for Lenny the second time I ever got paid.
First time I ever got paid to open for a guy named Warren Mcdonald,
who's a great guy.
Um,
and the second time I ever got paid to open up for,
for Lenny in Pittsfield at Jay's in Pittsfield.
I did that kick a punch of times.
Yeah.
That was a fucking,
Greg comes the first time I ever had sex with a black girl.
Really?
Writers on the stones Dum,
Dum,
Dum.
I didn't hate it.
No,
I think it was normal,
normal coverage,
but oh my God,
what a body shot.
But I was super white because I was living in Boston.
There was no sun and it was probably the winter.
And uh,
and I was a comic and she was super black.
She was really dark and I remember had sex by
the television,
the light of the television.
And it was like,
you know,
it's like,
her blackness and my way was very surreal.
It was very strange.
I remember,
I remember being black is black.
She was super hot.
She fucking her and I came so quick.
I still do.
I can't,
I fucking,
I can't control.
I can off often.
I come quick,
I'm fucking horrible.
I hate myself.
So it's just fucking horrible.
I'm checking off.
I'm so old,
I can barely get hard.
So now I'm jerking off and I'm coming with a sock with a semi hard Dick.
I have,
it's fucking,
I'm fucking up go out its moments,
but I've definitely done and I'm fucking her and I come quick and I'm like,
oh,
I'm shy.
She has,
don't worry,
it's not big enough anyhow.
Pretty low.
Right.
I mean,
don't want her to win a war.
Anyhow,
she was probably used to fucking mash.
Massive fucking,
you know,
there are some stereotypes that are true.
There's some double standards that are there.
They're there for a reason,
whatever.
But back to Boston county,
it was just,
we used to stay at this girl Barbara Swanson's house when we'd go up there,
there's some crazy broad,
she passed away,
had squirrels in our house,
pets and fucking just all kinds of shit running around.
And uh,
Jimmy Celeste,
one of the things about the east coast,
about Boston and about a New York was that there was a lot of places where you
could work is one of the few places where you could be a pro comic and you could
stay in that area and you could make a good living.
Yeah.
Long Island,
Connecticut,
Connecticut was a lot.
John Schuller.
Yeah,
his gigs.
Are you kidding me?
I function price.
He didn't manage me.
Brown and Thompson.
I did New Year's Eve there.
Very
Gig.
John Schiller.
He,
he helped me pay my rent and many,
many,
many a year are many,
uh,
um,
a week rather.
I did all of them.
Block showed carry Stanley fucking Shuler cakes for six,
seven years,
maybe all the early parts.
Like when I first started getting paid from then on.
Did you move from Boston to New York or did you go back and forth?
No,
I moved from,
I tried to keep my apartment and uh,
in New York when I came out to la.
But as far as like,
I've never been a,
I never had two places at the same time.
I just abandoned on my shit.
But when you came to la,
did you already have offers for shit already had a show.
He rang me.
I came out to do that Fox show,
it's called hardballs a baseball show.
I was in 94.
And um,
when that show got canceled then I got news radio right after that.
But I came out for that.
I was even gonna leave la and go back to New York.
I was miserable.
I just had a real hard time dealing with actors.
You are miserable in La.
He miserable first moved here.
I was so used to the New York comedy scene.
I was so used to comics and having fun all the time.
Like when we would work together,
if you and I were booked,
you know,
we're going to governors or something like that.
I'm like,
oh,
we're working.
I'm working with Voss.
We're gonna have some fun.
We'd go there,
we'd laugh,
we'd talk some shit and be great.
When you work with actors,
this great actors out there,
a lot of them are really nice people,
but the vast majority of them are empty,
vacuous Weirdos.
They're strange people.
It's a weird position to want to be like a pretender for living.
Constantly trying to get past and auditions.
You shed.
And I just had a,
I mean I met a lot of great guys like my friend Mike Star,
still still good buddy.
I love that guy.
I met a lot of really nice guys when I did my first show,
but I met a lot of fucking dummies man.
Fucking Bonnie has now.
I think there's some great actors,
like I'll watch,
you know,
I'll watch even like not even,
I need to me like a Morgan Freeman as good in everything.
He does everything,
you know,
uh,
and they're shutting the actors or actresses that are just fun.
But,
but comedy,
and this is Bonnie Sterian how much harder it is an acting.
And she says,
because kids and animals can act,
can't do comedy.
So true.
It's how much,
how hard comedy is and fucking acting.
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
It's,
you can either do it or you can't do it.
That's the other thing about it.
I'm not a good,
I mean,
I'm okay.
People Go,
you can't act.
I go while I'm a fucking comic.
You don't ask a fucking brain surgeon to do root canal.
Hey,
can you fucking fix this,
this molar?
No.
But if you have a tumor on your head,
come,
she ain't,
you know what I mean?
I could play myself,
you know,
or whatever,
but fuck,
fuck.
I could remember lines.
It's amazing when I'm watching him go,
how they remember all those fucking lines.
That's fucking insane.
How did you even dare fucking doing like,
you know what I mean?
Especially if you're doing a play,
I'm fine.
You know,
it's,
it's remarkable.
It's just a lot of work.
It's just put it to them.
It's nothing.
And,
and again,
there's comics are there,
I mean there's,
there's comics out there that are annoying and there's actors out there that are
great.
You're going to have both.
But I just missed that sort of type of sensibility.
Like the,
the comics,
when you,
when you're hanging out with comics,
you're always goofing off.
You're always having fun.
There's always like,
everyone's laughing at shit.
No one's no one is letting anybody get away with anything.
Like,
you know,
I remember who the fuck was it where somebody showed up with a hat on?
I think it was Brian Cowen showed,
oh that's what it was.
Brian Keller friend Jimmy Burke.
Brian Cowen showed up with a hat on like some sort of like a fedora and he's
like,
get that fucking stupid thing off your head.
Like what are you doing?
Like what did you think you are doing?
And Brian's like,
thank God he did that because what if I started wearing that day we were,
we went to shell.
She,
that's the whole fucking thing about New York and tough crowd in all.
And this was,
we were there way before this,
but you know the whole comedy cellar and the fucking Schmidt Kiss,
I don't know,
maybe six months ago,
eight months ago,
Peters walks
in in Russell's a pretty big act.
It's a big fucking new jack.
He comes in with his entourage and he's wearing a double breasted fucking pea
coat,
but it's waist high.
And the second we saw it,
Keith,
we couldn't stop fucking smashing him.
Right.
And Rosa,
Bonnie,
Bonnie said,
you look like the little boy on boardwalk empire,
which fucking,
I fell out of my seat.
Right Keith.
I mean,
we're fighting these fucking,
who's her?
His crew.
His crew couldn't laugh cause they could get fired.
They were like,
but we fucking,
it just cause she at the court and the table to sell on the back.
It's fucking sharks and you know,
even back in,
you know,
so next time he came in,
he's a little more fucking ready.
You know,
Russell's like he started slamming,
you know,
cause that's how he's not that type of comic.
And,
and I used,
I fight with money all the time.
Goes well,
everybody's not later.
Well fuck it then.
Don't come to that table because that's what's going to happen if you come to
that table.
I've come to,
I came to that table and I had a little pimple on my lip.
Fucking Kevin Hart.
Fucking poetry's Keith.
No,
they all started yelling for us.
Has her,
you're yelling it and singing it in the fucking dark.
Everybody was just a little bump,
you know,
so,
but,
but we would sit up there all night.
It would be me,
Norton,
mainly Keith and Patrice.
Just Smith.
Billy Bird,
fucking Billy comes into the cellar,
right?
And he says,
I'm going to the world series.
It's when the mets were playing the Yankees in the world series.
I saw Mike.
He goes,
I'm going to the game.
We go,
how the fuck,
how do you get tickets?
He goes,
well,
these dudes hired me to do a show on their bus on the way and are given and
right when he said that,
everybody's eyes lit up.
We're fucking,
we were,
we were.
We just delete this.
You guys were good crowd
and off the bus.
We beat him to sweat was pouring down Billy's head.
He didn't do it.
He gave the giggle away.
He didn't do the again because we beat up.
They're so hard.
So I mean it just fucking animals.
Eddie,
if came in there and he started talking to me and being arrogant,
he's gone.
Uh,
how much did you make or what do you do with this?
And I go,
well,
I don't know.
I made it.
He goes,
why me and Patrice?
Like he was Patricia.
Tell him.
He goes,
first of all,
he called him Eddie,
right?
Patrice,
you do colleges p you Versiti or something or you stink.
I don't know what he,
but he beat up Eddie if verbally for 40.
No one else jumped in.
It was such a beating.
It was such a bt.
I was driving home.
I had a cold,
nor did I go.
I can't stop laughing so that you don't get that in La and the cushion like in
new,
you can go to New York.
You fucking like you said,
you walk in when the wrong fucking hat or just your fucking shirt is too tight
or any imperfection.
Correct.
They're coming out to la.
They're like,
oh,
so what do you got?
What's going on?
Go Fuck Yourself.
Not Tell you what's not going on that fucking hair too.
That's,
that's the,
that's not going on.
Okay.
You fucking look like a Roman nickel.
Go Fuck Yourself.
But you can't do that here.
Well you can at the store.
They even have that,
that,
that comic battle every Tuesday night at midnight.
That's so packed.
You can't,
you can't even,
people are hanging from stairways just to hear it.
It's so packed.
And that's just two comics battling each other.
Gotcha.
Your stores maybe a row real renaissance.
Yeah.
To come back.
That cosmic battle was every night at the shelter at a table.
It's true and it was,
but it kept you on your fucking toes.
Dug Kevin Hall and Kevin was moving from New York to La.
We had a little thing at Boston comedy club,
right.
And he's on his,
he goes on stage to like say goodbye me,
Patricia and Keith and it was like 20 phone books in the back for summary.
We were thrown phonebooks books.
Adam,
as he's saying goodbye and all your solar's phone books,
he did cross the room at fucking dumb Kevin Hart who's making 20 fucking million
a movie,
little fucking news.
So it just makes you,
it makes you a better,
stronger stand fucking standup because you hang it,
you're hanging with strong fucking standups and you also recognize the holes in
your game.
Get exposed.
You know,
not everybody can do that.
No.
You know,
and and I,
and I would fight with fucking her.
Bonnie,
call me now.
Let me try.
Hello.
Are you seriously taking a phone call while we're in the middle?
Got to go.
I'm talking about,
I'm on Rogan's podcast.
Hi Bonnie.
Oh,
can hear that.
You just said,
why are you answering your phone then?
You do try it.
Funnies.
I shut that off.
Why would you think it's an emergency?
I'll be,
because she's driving home.
It's got damn podcast shut.
That thing.
Sorry.
Are you very clingy,
rich,
like you and Bonnie?
Like are you,
let me explain something to you.
Don't ever fuck you've been doing this 10 years.
Luckily have a surprise show tonight.
Okay.
No,
it just surprises you have a show that's a surprise.
Uh,
I know I'm not clingy.
She,
I'm only kind,
I don't mean to disrespect you and in your home,
uh,
is there,
has there ever been anything that people have said to you that had stung enough
where you overthink it?
It like,
like when you're doing these battles and you're getting riffed on like,
like I remember like long time ago people were saying like,
your ears smelled and like,
does that get to you?
Like,
oh shit,
my ears smell,
smell.
No.
The only time I had,
I had,
I had an all out.
It got pretty ugly with,
uh,
a bigger Leon Ona.
He came,
he was doing the virus tour one show.
Yeah.
And we squashed this,
but it's on you.
We squashed it,
but he didn't have the best set at deal.
And I was hosting those shows and that don't,
and enslaves me.
So he went on and he goes,
what do you want me to be like,
philosophy and work the crowd.
So he started going out to the crowd and it didn't go well.
So a widget,
it's not all his fault too.
They put them up towards the end of the show,
you know,
the show is going for fucking hours,
it wasn't all,
you know,
he should've had a better spot,
you know?
Yeah.
So I mean,
they're not fucking a fucking animals.
They're mutants.
Okay.
You're fucking their basement to weller mutants.
Uh,
so he,
but then he came into ona and he,
and it's,
you know,
I've been doing this show for fucking years and he started making fun of how I
talk and made some joke and he was being really arrogant and this and that.
And I go,
uh,
you know,
and I started and I'm,
I go,
let me make you feel in blue.
And then it just got worse and worse and it got really ugly.
But he was so passive aggressive about his fucking swarmy type of fucking humor
but don't come.
That's like when I just fucking trash chute,
which I shouldn't have because he says you're a fucking deal.
You know,
this is your deal.
I'm only kidding,
you know,
a little bit.
And so,
and uh,
but no,
there's nothing that,
you know,
we come from,
the radio I do when I do,
they're all fucking animals.
I know.
And a,
everything's a fucking,
you say something wrong or do this or that you're done.
You know.
Uh,
I heard the first day back when he sat and,
uh,
Anthony,
Chrissy,
he says,
it's fuck come.
I never really liked him anyway.
Let's get this audition started.
I go answer Anthony's chairs in fucking long island on.
But you know,
and no,
just sometimes fun.
That's what people don't understand.
Like it's,
it's great to be in that company.
It's good times.
People are so sensitive about goofing on each other.
People are so sensitive about people cracking jokes.
But if someone cracks a joke about something that you're doing,
most likely,
the reason why it's things is that,
you know,
they're right and you don't want to,
you don't want to admit that you're doing something goofy.
So you get all butthurt.
The only thing that gets me sometimes is dope.
When I slur.
And if someone,
you know,
may,
like the people on Twitter think they're my friends,
they think they are.
So they try,
they,
you know,
they're not,
you're not normal.
You're not Bobby,
you're not Billy,
you're not common.
They're insulting you.
And I go,
look,
you know,
there's,
I think there's a,
uh,
a Twitter handle blocked by Voss.
Uh,
I can block these cocksuckers all the time because they,
you know,
stop trying to get you to talk about and which you are,
you,
they're not nicknames blocked my boss.
So
that's true.
But they got you.
They got me.
So yeah,
there's not much,
I mean,
cause I'm a,
I'm a creep.
I fucking differences.
You're funny.
You know,
and some people do it and they don't know that they're not being funny.
They just,
some people that,
oh,
you can't take a joke when they're just being there,
just being shitty.
They're just being like a rude person.
Well,
it's not a joke and be funny,
you know,
it's just,
I don't know.
I mean,
cause you can't take a joke rich.
I married one and a mean as female comics on the planet.
She just fucking mean.
That's why we,
you know,
we fight nonstop,
but we come together when we find a victim that we both want to attack.
When there's somebody that we both can go after at the same time,
that's where our love really comes out for each other.
That's where you,
you know,
because like when our manager will call and say something stupid,
we'll just start fucking attacking them together.
Even when he hangs up with,
just keep it attacking until done.
And,
and,
and near Sar love the one that,
you know,
through combat.
I know bad cop and bad cop.
It's just when we come in,
people just,
Oh,
here they come.
And,
uh,
I just stuff all,
you're right.
The whole New York thing is so much,
it wasn't like that when I came out here.
When I came out here in 94 the comedy scene was very different at the store.
The store especially was a,
it was really barren.
It was weird.
I came,
I arrived and a real downtime there was like a real low,
it's like the,
the level of comics that you'd see there on the weekend.
It was very low.
It was weird.
It was like there was a lot of like a lot of bad comedy going on and then Martin
Lawrence search showing up and then Damon started showing up more and then you
start seeing like some big names that were coming there more and more and more.
And then I was,
I was coming up from the store in the mid nineties it started picking up again.
But when I came at night and my first came in [inaudible] 94 man,
it was a real low,
it was so disappointing because I was used to New York.
I was used to doing sets,
a danger fields.
I was used to doing the comic strip.
I was used to doing all these clubs and see all these great comics and all this
great energy and then every,
you know,
everybody fun having,
enjoying running into your friends and laughing a lot,
poking fun at Shit.
And then all of a sudden I was at this weird barren wasteland where everybody
was working to get a fucking development deal.
Everyone was like,
they all had these big fucking play dies and they were running around trying to
get a seven minute set together so they can get on the tonight show or get to a
MTV half hour comedy hour spots so they could,
you know,
get some sort of a development deal at a,
at a festival.
Was it completely different scene?
Yeah,
but we'll true like you said before,
there was no money to be made out here unless you did those things like back
there though,
which one night there was tons of weekend rooms back on the east coast.
A comic could like you like in La back then say on a weekend you did what?
The improv and a story when you do 15 minutes or whatever.
But back in New York,
you could go out to long island due east side.
Governors are chuckles if your headline and do 45 to an hour make money.
So now you're becoming a strong fucking comic.
Cause learn how to catch people's attention.
And he's Barsha.
Yes.
Yeah.
You're doing the one nighters during the week where you know some are good and
some are knife fights where you're going to go,
I'm going to win.
You know like Betty's fireside was a fucking,
this place was the thunder dome does it?
So many of those places.
You ever no guns.
Those gigs in Jersey last week.
Bob Gunzel.
It's fucking great room.
Yeah,
he had one on a cold last week.
What's the fucking one he had?
Uh Oh God that was fucking hit.
So many of them.
Yeah,
he had a bunch of them come and go.
They would come and go and there was one up on,
ah fuck.
I don't remember.
I just remember cause I got blown in the parking lot
on the shore.
I did one with auto and George and the shore.
That's what we did.
We did the one that she signed it the shore together.
We did at least one together.
We might have been more than one.
What we did want,
were you there?
The one where auto walked off stage where he like he was crushing.
Yes.
That yet.
That was the one he was racist shit.
Oh my God.
He was fucking destroying.
He was onstage.
I don't want to paraphrase what he was saying.
It was unbelievably racist shit know he's just dropping n bombs left and right.
I forget what the fuck it was,
but then he had like this weird look on his face,
like he had to get off stage and he left early and I remember everybody was
like,
what the fuck?
He was killing like why did he stop?
Then it was his guy,
Mike Austin and there was so many horrible fucking horrible and great.
You could work every night or great gigs and death.
I would go on the road.
She,
when I first started,
besides that I would go into road and host,
just go to Texas.
That's when I worked with Hicks.
I hosted,
I hosted for Sandy Diperna in Virginia Beach and Richmond,
you know,
just to get stage time,
I had to get on stage and get,
you know,
I remember me and fucking does comic Dennis Ross.
We drove to Connecticut.
We were getting 25 bucks a piece.
This was a long fucking drive.
So we get up,
we do our shows,
and the guy gives us 15 each.
No 10 [inaudible] we go,
it's supposed to be 25 the guy goes,
you had the salad bar.
I go,
go fuck yourself.
It's not $15 for a salad bar.
What are you talking about?
This salad?
Try to enjoy it.
He didn't want to give us 25 feet.
I mean,
we must have stung,
but he didn't want to give us 25 each that we drove.
But that's what you would do.
I mean,
comics still do it now.
You know,
they'll do fucking laundromats.
They'll do shows,
you know,
and Freddy's basement,
if there's enough for some guys got a show somewhere in la in a house.
Yeah,
I do.
Well,
I did.
Charlie Chaplin's house?
No,
no,
no.
This guys get like a living room.
Like he does comedy in the living room.
No.
Yeah.
Bunch of people.
Like I don't remember.
I don't know where the house is somewhere in la,
but like they have a stage set up.
You go on like,
like a very small stage and then all these people are sitting on the floor in
front of you.
Wow.
Wait,
wait a second.
I'm not kidding.
Somebody told me it was a fun gig too.
I'm doing a strip club with Duncan Trussell next month.
I like that guy,
Sam Tripoli and a few other people.
Where are you guys doing that?
Crazy crazy girls are,
I think that's what it is.
Um,
you're,
you're doing,
where is it?
In La?
Yeah.
And Hollywood.
I think it's the crazy girls in Hollywood.
Crazy girl.
We should do a strip club in Jersey called [inaudible]
boxcar.
And we would go up between Dan,
these dancers dance naked.
But it was bring your own beer show.
I mean they were,
you know,
just naked broads and now for the comic and sometimes you can know Norton did
it.
Florin keen levy me,
you know,
just all of us.
Wow.
But it was a weekend and it was like for 600 bucks or whatever.
And you're fucking those those gigs strengthen you.
Those drives home to it.
What the fuck am I doing?
I've,
I've tried,
I've driven home in tears.
I remember,
I remember doing this is,
I was,
if he stories are born,
just tell me,
but I fucking,
I was on the road doing a bunch of stuff in Florida,
so I'm down in Florida and just a bunch of horrible one nighters and all I keep
hearing on the radio is common.
Quintin Mario Joiner come to Miami and wash him tape that our HBO comedy
special.
So they were down there taping their specials,
you know,
and I was doing these shitty one sorta first and I'd always had a place,
there were puppets behind the stage behind it.
It was a,
not a Chucky cheese,
but another one.
But if you want me to curtain,
there was puppets there in the day for the kids and I'm doing fucking puppets.
Then the next night,
right,
the next night I'm going,
they're going to come in for pizza.
You have to do their specialist and see them work in a pup.
So the next night,
I mean homestead and some fucking horrible,
horrible,
I'm just barely making it through half bombing.
Half these fucking inbred motherfuckers and 40 minutes is up and I'm getting
ready to walk off.
Thank you again.
The owner walks up,
he's six foot something.
He holds my hand and he says,
I think you were very rude to the comic.
Uh,
he came all the way down here and I want you to be nicer.
He'll do another 20 minutes.
Ah,
fucking what?
So then I'm driving technologies.
Just do 20 minutes.
I just something maybe 10 of this and I drove,
I was driving to key Biscayne to do my last night,
I swear.
And then on the radio and I have two kids.
I miss them a homeward bound by Simon and Garfunkel comes on and just like
tears.
I'm crying as I'm driving to the gate,
you know,
I wish I was homeward bound and you know,
each town looks ashamed to me and I'm fucking all these shitty one nighters and
I'm crying and I get to the fucking last gig and I swear to God I'm on stage.
I just finished crying in my car,
which I've cried at a lot of them.
And this girl walks by in hot pants and she checked on me and she has a wooden
fucking leg in hot pants.
You don't fucking wear hot pants where we could see what a leg attaches to the
fucking nasty fucking.
And I just fucking bitch,
I'll beat you with your leg.
Go leave me the fuck alone.
And I just,
you know,
and I drove and I got home and I,
it was just a lot.
I drove there to Florida and just horrible one nighters.
I had kids,
I had to make money,
I had to make fucking match.
When I started doing the black circuit,
I started doing urban clubs.
You did def jam?
Yeah,
I was the first white comics.
You do def jam and went on for five years and they go and I was doing the black
clubs and the next year if they w they were supposed to stop,
I would have been the only white guy.
But then they did it the next year and they had a couple more.
But I was doing the black clubs too.
I had to earn fucking money.
I had two kids,
a house,
you know,
and you know,
I didn't have TV credits then.
So you would just do fucking,
you know,
I was doing fucking clubs in the Bronx and in fucking Harlem and,
and,
and Newark that,
you know,
black comics were scared to go in.
Okay.
Will,
I'm not bullshitting,
you know,
peppermint lounge just club was fucking brutal.
You champagne comedy club in Mount Vernon?
No.
Was it in Malvern?
Newest Shell might've been new shell.
There was a place in new Rochelle.
There's a black club called the champagne comedy club.
Fuck it.
You had to keep it clean.
Uh,
I could never do it.
I keep it clean.
Yeah,
it was one of,
um,
my friend Jon Tobin went in there,
John John Doe radio before John was on the radio.
John was a comic and uh,
he was,
um,
he was on set and that's where I first saw Reggie McFadden.
I think I might've seen him once before and it's short set.
But that was when the first time I ever saw Reggie McFadden.
[inaudible]
yeah.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
that guy's talented.
I was,
I was blown away.
I couldn't believe how funny I thought that guy was the next any Murphy.
I'm like,
I'm watching the hawks gigantic superstar for sure.
I was like,
this is no way this kid is so much fucking talent.
But the guy had like all these rules,
like he couldn't say.
He like he would say before the show,
no motherfuckers,
I don't even know mother fuckers.
He goes,
you don't say ass.
You don't say that bitch had a big ass.
You say that woman that had a wide behind,
she had like rules.
He would tell you how to do your comedy.
This is the champagne comedy club hamburger.
I want to say Mount Vernon,
but it might've been new Rochelle,
I'm not sure,
but it was in that area.
I did one,
I did one terminal date and I was hosting the show.
And this,
I'll tell you,
two of them I was hosting,
I'll tell you to go all the,
fuck that one I was doing fuck down.
I was working,
there was a,
uh,
Justin's a one night or New York and I get on,
I'm onstage and it's going well.
And then I start fucking bombing.
I mean,
and like in a black audience will love you or they'll turn on you just,
there's no way do I need,
it's just,
we'll give you some lead way,
but wait on.
And he says,
you know,
you're,
you,
you can become a delusional conic would white audiences because you think you're
good.
It's just that they're not as outgoing as black audiences that will let you know
you're not good.
You know?
So I started,
I was really bombing and someone in tobacco gave me the siren,
you know,
the,
from the showtime at the Apollo when earn.
So I heard the time and I go,
fuck you.
You don't know what the Fuck I've done.
I snapped.
I go,
uh,
you know I've been on this show that show this show.
I got a 15 years sober.
I've been on HBO.
I had done this stat.
I go,
what have you accomplished?
And the whole place went fucking silent.
I walked off and it was puffy.
That was given.
It was his club.
It was bumpy.
That was giving me the siren.
What have you accomplished?
God so lit.
Puffy before he was p did it?
Yeah.
It was puffy at the time.
Which his place.
That is fucking funny.
Boy.
You wrong.
Yes.
It's just there are so many.
When I taped def jam,
I did a bit from this,
but when I taped def jam,
I went to one of the tapings just to watch tonight before so guide Tori was to
warm up and he came out.
He said,
look,
this is not the Apollo.
We do not boo here.
This is HBO.
We don't fool with respect to comics and let's have a good show.
I ran into him the other night.
He's a nice,
nice,
just kind of great guy.
Fucking clothes guy.
I don't know Joe like actually rented a Joe recently,
but guy used to do um,
fat Tuesday at the store.
She guy all the time guys.
Fantastic.
And Joe's cool to,
Joe was like one of the first really yolked up comics till you go on stage with
like a vest on giant arms.
He was,
yeah,
he was fucking guy was huge.
Posse.
It was fucking,
he was fucking,
he was uh,
he was jacked.
Angel Angel Salazar was the first pumped after he got fucking smacked around.
So he pumped up a little,
but he got smacked around.
Yeah.
To store two years ago.
What happened?
I think Kennison smacked him around.
Tennyson beat up angel sounds a story.
I don't know it,
so I don't want to tell it.
I don't cause I don't know the whole story.
That's funny.
So I go watch his conduct on depth champ.
I go watch the taping and no booing.
So there's black comic comes out,
this is in New York.
And the first thing he says,
I want to show it off by saying,
first of all,
I'm not from New York.
I'm from Canada.
Strike one.
Then he had an old gold suit on.
He looked like a century 21 salesman strike two and then the next joke he
bombed.
So when a black audience cam,
Ooh,
you,
all you heard through the ordinance was,
hmm
mm
child.
And so they would let you know.
But if they,
if a black audience liked you,
they fucking loved you.
I mean you would fucking kill.
I did it.
Black Casino,
same thing.
[inaudible] the whole time.
Is there a nicer guy than guide toward,
is there a nicer guy?
He was,
he was,
might be like the nicest guy ever.
He's just,
every time I shave him he's just,
he's just a sweetheart.
Yeah,
it was a good guy.
Funny fucking dude too,
man.
He's what needs,
he's been a lot of movies.
He does a lot of radio too.
Doesn't,
he didn't used to do,
he used to do a radio show out of La and it was like in Atlanta or something
like that.
And you'd get up early in La,
do his radio show.
What was he on that guy from?
He was unjoin a shell.
I think he had his own show.
I think he had like a syndicated show for awhile.
I don't know.
Every time I see him it's a pleasure to see them.
Yeah.
Like I said,
him and his brother,
they're both cool as fuck.
Uh,
funny dudes,
man.
Funny dudes.
The the Lac and has got a lot better than it was in 94.
But uh,
the New York scene has always been like a little edgier.
I wonder if it's like just the cold weather,
you know,
just the fucking bitterness of the winters in New York.
I wonder what it is that just speed of life.
Yeah.
It's also,
there's so many more fucking people like on top of each other in some weird way.
Well,
they don't have to interact with each other the same way in la.
Yeah.
You're never wins in their car.
They go to a house for the most part,
the ice house and the Improv and the laugh factory and the comedy store.
We're all like in the same street,
you know?
And then there was another street next to or all.
How about in La itself?
Like if just like Hollywood,
like you think about how many,
how many comedy clubs are actually in Hollywood?
There's quite a few,
but nothing compared to New York.
New York's got like a hundred clubs.
There's clubs literally might be a hundred comedy clubs in New York City.
There might be,
there's some,
I mean alternative or,
Oh yeah.
If you start counting in Brooklyn and oh by the way,
Ari,
you should.
Fear is going to be at the Bell House in Brooklyn Tomorrow night.
If you're in a,
if you're in Brooklyn,
he's preparing his new comedy special that he's going to record.
That's October 29th in La at the comedy store in the original group.
That sets a bad ass crazy place.
And Ari has a new podcast and I'm telling you,
man,
I don't break up too easy,
but I was crying listening to this.
He has a new podcast.
It's um,
it's Jonah Ray.
I think it's number one 80.
And Jonah raises guest.
But along the way during the beginning of the podcast is all him talking about
his journey from an open microphone
is first time on stage to finally getting passed at the comedy store after four
fucking years of constant auditions to him,
eventually getting a comedy central special and is going to record it,
film it at the comedy store in the original room and he's crying when he's
saying this.
It's incredible.
It's one of the most motivational and inspirational things I've ever heard.
A comic too fucking incredible.
Is there something in particular that that makes it sad?
Like dizzy,
sad.
He's emotional,
he's happy,
you know,
it just means so much to him.
You know,
he's just talking like I'm breaking up,
talking about,
he was just talking about how,
um,
how much it meant to him and um,
how,
how hard he worked for it.
And he just,
you know,
he kept saying it like,
it's,
it's my home.
It was really intense,
man.
Like I'm seriously breaking up.
I'm talking about it.
It's really intense.
It's a,
you got to listen to it because you know,
and he's,
he's super honest with himself,
super honest about the whole thing.
It's pretty,
pretty amazing.
That's pretty amazing stuff.
So that's October 29th,
and then he's,
like I said,
he's at the,
um,
at the Bell House tomorrow in Brooklyn today being what?
What's Today's date?
The 19th 20th.
Today's the 20th.
The Bell House in Brooklyn.
The 21st of August,
2014 go fuck yourself.
Uh,
I like him.
He's awesome.
He,
he's most improved player of the decade award.
Motherfucker.
He works hard there.
Guy Puts in work.
Art should.
Fear is a discipline man.
He gets shit done.
I respect the fuck out of that.
The guy writes,
he writes a lot.
So important man.
So important.
It's just effort plus,
you know,
results,
effort equals results rather.
He knows if you don't see progression,
if you're not
fucking advantage or stagnating,
you know what I mean?
You got to just keep reinventing.
And Dylan and Dylan,
she's got a right to do that.
The number one thing,
man,
this,
it's hard.
It's people get lazy,
man,
come out with new shit.
Especially when you're known and people are coming to see you again.
[inaudible] so you gotta hadn't,
you know,
fuck it out.
New stuff.
You Know Louis C k a a 15 minutes.
We'll have another hour.
Hold on.
Yeah it will write it in 50 hell habit at at five o'clock west coast time.
Y'All ilab another hour.
Yeah.
He's interesting when he talks about it too.
Cause Louie,
um,
he's got a computer you can't get on the Internet was,
and that's what he writes on.
So he can't like jerk off or look at new cars are fucking think about buying a
jet,
you know,
he just has can only right.
I,
you know,
like sometimes I blame my,
uh,
failure on,
well I got kids this and that,
but Louie has kids,
he has everything that,
you know what I mean?
And He seems to get it done,
he seems.
Do you do a podcast by herself or only with Bonnie only.
Would Bonnie,
you ever thought about doing one by herself as well,
since tour by yourself
sometimes.
Right.
I told him by himself all the time.
Why don't you do a podcast by yourself too?
I was thinking it because we have,
do you tell these stories on your podcast with her?
No.
These are great fucking story.
These stories should all be on a,
on a podcast and I know you've got a hundred more of them.
Yeah,
I know you do.
Fucking all you have is stories and you should have,
you should have your own podcast.
I should have done,
I should try it once.
You know,
look at you already backing down dude.
Now just do it.
Start now.
Ready.
The rich muck podcast starts now.
Compound testing,
testing.
Oh Shit.
That's how I start my other one.
You know it in it.
It starts when you're fucking,
here's the deal for a good comic.
For me,
a good comic.
Like you'll like,
you'll see conflicts and I've said this in many interviews,
you know,
and I think a good artist too or any type is somebody that works from,
from their,
from their heart.
You know what I mean?
Like when you walk out of fucking Stan hope show,
you go,
I know this fucking dude.
Right?
Okay.
When you walk out a college show your show.
And that's,
don't get me wrong.
That's for me,
that's the kind of comedy I think is what I like is fuck.
Oh man,
he's telling me about what the fuck you,
I talked about my house burning down,
you know,
and I tried to make it funny or whatever.
Or you know,
obviously we have kids in that shit,
but,
and then there's the other comedy from here that just certain ones that are so
fucking funny.
You Go,
well that's funny,
but then you go,
or what the fuck did he,
what was he talking about?
I don't know,
but he was fucking funny.
That's quite look Harlan Williams.
Perfect example.
Yeah.
Harlan's hilarious.
But yeah,
you get off the fucking,
you leave the room.
They're like,
what the hell did he talk about?
He talked about about her not flap Jack flapper jaw,
you know me,
Kissy Lips,
he'll see shit.
You'll be,
you'll be howling.
But you're like,
what the fuck is he talking about?
I'm the one to 10 scale.
I don't want to 10 scale.
He's at 10.
He's and is a 10 as a person too.
He's a great guy.
I don't know him.
Harland was breast so nice.
Uh,
well,
you know,
we're,
we're talking about to me,
nice guys.
Let's get to the assholes.
Uh,
cause there's a lot.
so,
but here's what,
to me,
what I think makes
to me a great comic and you know,
I fucking like,
I've seen Stan hope a little,
but I've read some of his stuff and I'm going,
I can never,
I'll never write that good.
You know,
when he writes a fucking blog or cause,
you know,
and I'm going,
it's just brilliant shit.
And,
and what it is that makes somebody fucking great probably as a musician,
as an actor,
as,
as an artist is life experience and what you've been through in life.
So if you've been through fucking drug addiction recovery to force kids,
this neighborhood,
that neighbor grown up fighting cry whenever,
you see what I'm saying?
You get some 22 year old kid that,
you know,
the industry is fucking fallen over.
What the fuck.
You know what I mean?
Do they really know what can they,
well,
they can't really know,
but they can still have talent.
I mean,
Chapelle was hilarious when he was 18 I first saw him and he was like 18 years
old.
He was a what was his past before eight that's true.
That's true.
Well,
how about Hicks?
I don't think hex had much going on in his life.
That was crazy.
I mean,
I'll finish exception subject doesn't know violence,
right?
I Dunno.
I mean,
maybe I'm wrong.
I could be wrong.
It's true.
As true.
It's possible that someone just has an insanely good sense of humor and then
with life experience it gets better.
You know?
I think that's certainly possible because I know the guys that were not good
when they were 21 they're great now,
not 35 and they're really fucking awareness 14 years,
but it took hundred 14 years and,
and the things in life that happened to him at 14 years.
Any other shit,
of course.
And even trying to be a comic,
just the devastating effects of trying to be a comic and being rejected and
bombing build character.
So in like inadvertently it made him a comic by sucking at being a comedy
because comedy is,
look,
you need a fucking audience to tell you you're good or bad.
You can't sit at home and practice.
You can do certain things at home,
you can write,
you can write stuff down,
but then it has to grow in front of an audience.
You have to have an audience.
You could,
you could sing at home for a year straight and get,
become a better singer,
I'm sure.
Right?
I don't know about saying,
but you know,
back like I say there,
she's Bro,
you know,
they had bringer shows back east,
which is the worst,
you know,
comics to get on stage have to bring fucking people,
which is fucking brutal.
Cause first of all,
it's tough enough to do comedy now they're producers.
So it's tough enough to bring people and be funny if I,
but what's even tougher is being one of those fucking friends driving home into
comic going,
no,
you did well,
you know,
you and you know,
that's what's tough is that Fred all the way home.
Shit.
Brutal.
Fucking brutal.
So I don't know what,
you know,
I just,
I,
I don't know.
Maybe I'm not like,
I studied,
like that's why I,
I,
I really loved Bonnie because she knew comedy.
She fucking knew comma,
he lived Cami.
That's what,
this wasn't just some girl that I could be,
she history and writing shit and brilliant,
you know,
new this one,
that one,
you know,
fucking Newhart,
woody Allen and Landesberg and all these,
you know what I mean?
I'm going [inaudible] to me,
she just,
you don't,
plus she was fucking,
you know,
she was fucking hot.
But you know what I mean?
And as just,
I
don't want to sound like some old fucking,
you know,
relic comic,
but you know,
there's some new comics should are great.
You watch them,
but do they know,
do they,
you know,
they,
they didn't see the dean,
the Dean Martin Roast or the Dean Martin Roast.
You didn't,
nope.
None of them.
Nope.
He didn't want to.
You have,
you didn't see any of sorry.
Oh No,
didn't,
oh,
I'm not a row sky.
I don't like roasts facility because I like,
I like when people bust on each other.
Look,
but I don't like when they do it in front of a crowd.
I think like when it comics fuck around with each other in like in private,
it's hilarious to me.
It's so funny,
like seeing Pr Patrice laughing at you about something.
It's the great moments.
But the difference between that and doing it in front of a crowd where people
get on the die,
the ds or the whatever they call the thing,
the Deus Deus,
but your notes out there and you shit on everybody.
I always find that to be like so fabricated.
It just,
I don't like it.
Well,
ish fabric.
Yeah,
but it feel,
it feels fabricated.
Like I understand that some people enjoy it,
but styles and things that people don't enjoy.
I don't enjoy that kind of comedy.
Well,
here's why Roche on is as good as the back then when because they're not
friends.
They don't,
exactly.
That's what I'm,
that's what my point is.
It just mean to each other.
Yeah.
Amy Schumer,
when she'd roasted,
when Mike Tyson was in the crowd and she brutalized Mike Tyson.
Did you ever see that?
I think it was a Charlie Sheen's rice roast.
That was actually pretty fucking funny.
Amy Schumer destroyed Mike Tyson.
Amy Schumer is a funny bitch.
She's fucking funny.
She's fucking funny man.
That chicks,
she throws heat
if you slip,
you know shit fucking take you out,
man.
She's funny dude.
But she hung up that table fuck cash table at the comedy cellar.
That's where you know,
I don't know Jerry Seinfeld,
but it's really fascinating.
Like Amy has like this,
this sort of issue with the Jerry Seinfeld's like nonacceptance of diversity and
comedy and it's like,
I think particularly women,
like there's something about it.
Like when we had her on the show,
she was pretty upset,
um,
about this one thing that Jerry Seinfeld did.
It was,
um,
there was this a thing for comedians in cars getting coffee and they had gone
over all the people that had been on the show and they were like,
everybody's a white man.
Like,
where's the fucking diversity?
And Jerry Seinfeld goes,
look,
I don't,
I don't speak diversity.
I speak funny.
Are you funny?
If you're funny,
then I'm interested in what you have to say,
but I don't care if you're black or white.
I just care about funny.
She wasn't hearing it,
she wasn't buying it,
and she was like,
I just,
no,
I don't,
I don't think that's what's going on.
I don't like it.
And it doesn't,
I don't,
I get offended when he says that.
Like,
wow,
she knew because she knows him,
you know,
she's had experience with them.
So I thought that was pretty fascinating and it coming from anybody else.
I might go,
ah,
she's just fucking sensitive.
But Amy Schumer is a bad ass bitch.
No,
she is.
She gets what she wants.
She's not sensitive,
you know?
I mean she's not over sensitive,
so I was like,
Huh,
but here's you know it,
it's his,
it's hundred percent.
If he wanted to do it the same four people over and over again,
it's his prerogative and he could do that.
It's like him.
That's like him saying to her,
how can we not putting this person on your shell?
You know everybody goes to the diversity thing is diversity is is easy to
attack,
fucking attack diversity.
But you know what,
there's not diversity throughout life and a lot of things.
While we were talking about at lunch today,
we're talking about the Nobel prize winners in the size of how many European
Jews.
Yes there are that are like super genius.
European Jews mean it's kind of crazy and I'm not going to give a Nobel prize to
some fucking guy from Uganda that had two months in fucking in med school
because you know,
you know what I'm saying?
So diversity is and racism and the race card is a quick way out of it and female
card and all that.
I agree.
Amy Schumer has gotten everything she's gotten cause she's funny and works hard.
So I mean I don't know what she's fucking,
she kills he,
I don't know what the issue was or why it was kind of got to go deeper than
yeah,
she didn't want him to do it though.
She was like dancing around.
I tried to get her to talk about it,
you know,
she was not interested but you know,
I respect that,
you know,
she's,
everyone has their own path.
But see the reason why I would harp on it,
it's cause she's not sensitive because she could hang at that table cause she's,
she's fucking funny.
Play that thing with her and Mike Tyson the road.
She's sharp.
She is rude.
I just sent her a text.
She is,
Patrice stole that fucking roast.
He fucking stole that is part of that rose.
Oh yeah,
he was a monster.
He was so funny.
Fucking,
he was so funny because he was so funny the way he would bust balls too.
Like one time I called up and Anthony was talking about guns and he's talking
about carrying guns and,
and I was like,
um,
I go,
don't you ever worry that like having this gun around all the time,
like you're constantly holding on the guns.
We got guns are any house that it may be like you might manifest something and
uh,
Patrice go see Joe Rogan believes in magic.
He goes,
Joe's magical.
He's like conjuring shit.
Huh?
Do you ever seen a bit dated?
I know I didn't see the whole thing.
Who could catch a cab quicker?
Well,
they said the nonsuit the nigger was the bit trees would,
uh,
we'd go out and they would pick up the Nazi twice as much as they would pick up
a trees.
Susan.
It was unbelievable.
So ridiculous.
Oh,
and they had some of the fucking funniest gags ever.
Oh yeah.
To this day,
baby bird is the funniest thing I've ever been a parking laugh to this day.
Posture's
thing.
Wow.
That's a beautiful HD video has shot by someone taking a cell phone video of a
cell phone video from the moon.
See if we could find another version of that that's just so bad.
We can't even air that.
It does sound like shit.
Well we,
we should do Roche at Boston Comedy Club,
but we were all friends like we've,
there's some of them somewhere like those trees Norton me,
you know,
and it was all friends on these fucking Roche.
So it was kindness.
They stood up for what he thought was wrong.
What was wrong,
wasn't it?
And you getting screwed by somebody getting too much money or something.
No,
no.
For some show doing coke and they fired him.
He was smoking mad amounts of freebase and doing blow allegedly.
And they fired him because he was talking about it all the time.
Like how could that be like whatever.
But most of that's funny shit.
Oh Shit.
Actually it was Adley like he told me that that's not what he had planned a lot
of it because
shit about him that's kind of staying close.
Huh?
That's what some of those had of stilling.
The Jessalyn they're corn.
Yeah.
I talked to him two nights before for like two hours I was talking to on the
phone for that.
I'm not just trying to,
it just cause we were,
you know,
like what the fuck am I doing?
I don't like these mother fuckers.
It comes from like I said,
look,
I'm going to put you over the top.
I mean he was going to do it,
but he just was,
he needed other people say just fucking do it,
isn't it?
You know,
but cause he said I,
he turned down a bunch of them because he didn't know the people.
He was roasting,
Roasting Norton and me,
Bobby and Collin were up there and Keith,
he wouldn't do it.
You know what I mean?
He doesn't know these fucking people and he thinks and he was true and he
thought and he was 100% right.
He's had a whole nother level than all of them.
So who are they to talk about me?
You know what I mean?
That's what he's thinking.
Like who is this motherfucker to talk about me?
And that's what it doesn't make sense about him.
That doesn't like to say something about it.
I mean,
that's the next a funny cat man.
I,
you know,
he's a funny dude.
That's kind of her funny dude,
you know.
But how many years ago was that?
That was like three,
four years ago.
Right now,
you know,
but just on next to funny fucking guy.
I mean,
but at the time Patrice,
like who the fuck is,
hey,
Amy wasn't as big as she was four years,
you know,
over the cow.
That's what made her famous.
And a lot of ways that's what put her over the top.
Well,
her hard work,
but that,
you know,
it's like once she did that,
then people got a chance to pay attention.
All the other stuff that she was doing well,
but a lot of,
you know,
a lot of them killed fucking,
what's her name?
Natasha had a line of her line and this was one of the best roast lines I ever
fucking heard.
Uh,
she said,
so we play it.
I played too much roast,
let's play it cause the doshas on soon.
Anyway,
it was funny to me.
Yeah.
What Roche was it?
It was the Charlie Sheen rose,
right?
No,
no,
no.
Was Franco James Franco.
Yeah,
that was it.
Natasha.
Alicia fucking the one line,
you know,
to why they beep and shit.
There's some kind of tried to find the uncut version out.
When was this place is fucking dull.
This place is buzzing.
Oh,
that's around as he's his family.
That's the bugs family
disease.
Holy Shit.
She was,
I thought that was funny.
He's funny man.
She's fucking fucking funny.
That's fucking good dude.
Did you watch that?
Steevo a video?
No,
no.
We were talking about it before the podcast.
You showed me a picture of it.
But is he going public with this?
Oh yeah.
He tweeted it and put it on his own youtube and he told me before he was going
to do it,
cause I was in San Diego when he did it and he and I was like saying the same
thing you said to me.
Well it's like this is like bad you,
you would get in a lot of trouble for this.
Let's explain what he did right here.
Let's just watch it.
Here's the video.
Well,
let's tell people at home that are putting my foot down for Shaman.
He's printing out a sign at Kinko's.
Yeah.
He's printing out a giant sign that says sucks and he's throwing up a rope to
the top of this billboard or a traffic sign where,
uh,
he's climbing this fucking rope with his crazy like during the day
and it's during the day.
Yeah.
He had to get gloves.
He was tearing his hands apart.
So he's just climbing is fucking rope to the top of this traffic sign.
And then,
uh,
it says seaworld and he's going to write sucks next to it.
Now they got some guys from the local beach too to help just pull him up by his
ankle
on a rope.
Yeah,
they're all pulling him up.
His kids,
he's trying to figure out how to get up there.
If you fall from there,
by the way,
you're fuck Ceville no one called the Felice like he's a terrorist.
He's hanging by his ankle.
Oh Shit.
Oh fuck.
Dude.
Day Too.
That's a bad way to fall.
He fell on his head.
How's he?
Okay.
It's made out of rough.
Oh Shit.
Oh my God.
He fell again.
He says Jack.
Yes.
Went and got a goddamn ladder at home depot.
A ladder that he's climbing up to the top of this traffic sign.
He's crazy and he's putting the sticker that he had printed up on.
Kinko's got the wrong color green unfortunately.
And it says sea world sucks.
This chain of jumping
stripe here.
See where on the other hand,
sex terror.
So share this video with the Hashtag.
See what else sucks.
Yeah.
He did a flip off the roof into a swimming pool.
We seen that video before.
No,
I don't even want to see that shit gives me anxiety.
I can't even watch it at three.
They get us.
We were talking about before the podcast is that that's kind of illegal.
It has to be like a federal offense,
like fucking with male type situation.
I don't think you're right.
Private property.
It's vandalism.
I don't think it's private property.
I think it's federal property.
I'm pretty sure date side of the highway.
The state.
Okay,
let's,
let's Google it.
How illegal is it to deface a sign,
a traffic sign?
I saw the traffic sign.
Yeah.
That's uh,
advertisement sign or whatever.
Right.
But it's not a billboard.
It's fine now how illegal.
Yeah.
I'm just surprised in San Diego,
super military,
you see a guy with a bunch of ropes climbing a sign that people aren't like
calling the police.
Like,
Whoa,
dude,
there's some terrorists,
you know,
assign trying to build up,
not one.
Yeah.
I'm trying to find it.
This is probably gonna be a annoying to try and figure out and I'm sure he got a
lawyer.
A law though.
It seems like a city.
A city ordinance.
I might be wrong though.
I Dunno.
Do you face highway travel?
Me when we were at highway traffic side,
because it might be different.
The difference between defacing a a traffic sign on a,
um,
on a regular street that might be like less illegal possession of a traffic
sign.
By the way,
this is this is that,
uh,
at the end,
this isn't a San Diego News.
At the end of the video,
he says,
if doing that was wrong,
I don't want to be right.
Scree zeroed Glover's comment below the video says,
be an awesome person by sharing this video with the Hashtag c road sucks.
And then he released the statement,
uh,
about Steve Video Confession and,
and he says,
we consider defacing public property at a cost of state taxpayers and Unlawful
Act in a dangerous distraction for motorists.
We all refer all information to the California highway patrol,
but he didn't really,
you know,
oh,
it was just a sticker.
They just had to peel it off.
So there was no damage.
But yeah,
but he would have sat about distracting people.
That is an issue.
That is an issue,
especially now because people are going to hear about it from his video are
going to go looking for it.
Yeah.
He shouldn't do that.
He could go to jail for that shit.
It's just amazing that he's okay.
I know Paul's falls.
He fell fucking twice,
once on his head and the other time is ladder broke.
I mean,
he's ridiculous.
That's he fell from fucking really high up,
man.
That's what it's made out of rubber.
Do you think there's some people that's bodies can just take it a little bit
better?
Like it's just,
Oh,
I don't know.
His volunteer have all been broken in and you know,
he's just,
he knows how to fall,
you know?
I think he knows how to stay relaxed.
He probably felt right here.
It fell a little bit higher than he would have fun.
Wouldn't it be fucked if he got paralyzed when he was putting up a seaworld
sucks.
He could have easily right phone hanging by his ankle and he falls on his head
and machine.
No,
he's fucking selling and working in the ticket booth that she world because he
only fucking move with his fucking head are now.
Everybody was wanting to cc
mouth.
Divo get you ticket for you.
Yes.
He has to blow in this draw to make the ticket come up.
I got to take it from Steve.
He's all head now.
It's weird.
Doesn't eat light bulbs.
Just crazy.
Fuck you.
But he breaks light bulbs and cuts his tongue up with him.
He's so crazy,
like some of the shit that he's done.
It's just so hard to watch
comedy clubs.
Comedy clubs cracked me up man.
Like if fucking,
uh,
somebody got upset at him,
somebody who was it out,
she got upset at him
because of a,
you know,
they were like,
he's not a real comic.
You makes me laugh.
He does a good show,
I think.
Well,
I mean,
look if in some clubs and say,
hey listen,
if Cameron Diaz called a club and said I wanted to do next week,
they would go,
all right,
we'll give you Friday,
Saturday.
You know,
it's,
if they could sell tickets for sure it's so fucking ticket.
But he does,
he actually doesn't act like he hasn't asked if he's,
he,
he's very good story telling you like very storyteller,
but he puts his little jokes and stabs and stuff in there.
So I mean he does it right.
Like he,
he's been doing it for a long time.
Like he does it a little bit like I think it's used to public talking and stuff
because he used to be in the circus growing up and stuff like that.
So he's just always been an entertainer his whole entire life.
I,
you know,
I love when a guy like Patrice makes fun of Shit.
You know,
I think it's Hilarious,
but I really don't honestly personally have a problem with anybody's style of
comedy.
And I might not like it,
but I'm not going to,
I don't,
it doesn't upset me.
No,
not at all.
Hacky shit upsets me if I have to follow it.
You know,
like if you watch a guy who's just doing something terrible,
the real problem is if someone's doing something terrible,
it can get in your head and then it gets you,
puts you in a bad mood and you don't,
you don't think anything's really funny.
You're not like in the right state cause he listened to this terrible act.
Well it's not the act I hate as much as the audience for laughing at it and be,
I told you,
I said,
have you got one inch?
I've Dev skill.
No,
but they don't know any better.
Joe Just,
you know,
they're watching storage wars and they're fucking,
what did they know about,
hey look at this dude just said fucking,
I'm the only ship to Kilkee.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
Do you remember when it was,
when you were just going to comedy clubs before you actually became a comedian?
I only went to,
Shit.
I went to two,
two times to a comedy club twice.
I went to penny arcade and catch a rising star.
I remember going and being shocked at how easy it is to make people laugh.
I was like,
I don't understand what's going
on here.
Like stuff that doesn't make me laugh is getting people to laugh,
but stuff that I thought was funny back then.
Now I think it's unbelievably terrible.
Like within a year or two,
I saw it through like,
there was a lot of comics that I was coming up with that were like a couple of
steps ahead of me that were middling.
They were doing well and uh,
you know,
they're pros.
They would work on the road a little bit.
And I remember that they would be at a comedy club.
I'd be like,
Whoa,
that's such and such.
He's a pro.
And then like two years later I'm like,
oh,
that guy's terrible.
Oh,
I thought he was a pro.
He's,
he's dog shit.
He's never going anywhere.
I mean,
and I think he's still funny.
Why haven't you seen Jack?
But I went to catch Roger shot or second time I went to see comedy and I was
watching Hiram Castin I go to,
she is the funniest man alive.
I used to funnyish made,
but I didn't know.
He just,
you know,
I mean,
I knew comedy from growing up to know his act.
It was just an old [inaudible] style.
I just,
I should come home from school in fourth grade.
No,
not for second,
second or third grade.
And I figured out later in life,
you know,
my parents were divorced going through a divorce and a horrible,
we have to live here without dad and you know,
and,
and I guess my comfort zone was such in a comedy and I will come home from
school every day and listened to Vaughn meter.
Uh,
the first family,
uh,
he did Kenny the impressions and it was the funniest thing on the planet.
He had the Kennedys down to a science,
to a science,
and he was the hottest comic back then.
And then the Kennedys were assassinated.
He liked,
they say he went from Park Avenue to park bench.
He was,
he died of alcoholism,
I'm pretty sure.
But he was,
if you never heard it,
I mean,
he just,
it was the first family Vaughn meter.
Did you ever get to see,
uh,
what was his name?
Bob Woods I worked with,
I've worked with what told me,
I could tell you a good crack.
Shorty would,
would a good drug shortage.
We,
uh,
Bob will tell everybody who Bob woods was.
Bob Woods was this big legend in like the long island.
Seeing you're like,
a lot of guys ripped that guy off.
Bob Woods was,
he looked like a bait captain.
Kangaroo.
He had curly blonde hair,
a mustache,
big,
sweetest guy on the planet.
Not,
you know,
he helped,
like he would help younger guys.
You know,
you're just a nice guy.
He was a pot.
He drank,
he partied.
He,
he just was,
his dream was to work rascals,
headline,
rascals.
That was his dream.
So,
and we did tons of one night,
or if we did this,
we did Betty's fireside,
like I said,
which was the thunder dome,
this place,
he leaped over to bar.
This guy was gigantic on a guy to fucking dish,
you know,
rip them to pieces for just nonstop heckling.
You just saw Bob just fucking leap.
Uh,
but a sweetheart too,
you know what I mean?
So me and him,
we did a,
we did some one night or we go,
let's go get some,
some cracks and freebase uh,
we'll go up to Harlem.
Uh,
I don't even know if he ever tried it.
I might've said,
you've got to try this shit or whatever.
Or he might've done it.
I don't know.
So we took a cab up to Harlem,
Spanish Harlem.
We bought a bunch of freebase.
So we said to the cab driver,
can you take us to New Jersey?
We were going to Epilito Shouse,
chip CUNY or whatever,
and we're in the back seat and to cab drivers going,
you gotta be careful on this shared.
So there's stuff out here called crack and they'll kill you over it.
And the whole time we're in the backseat smoking it.
So then the cab drivers sees a smoke and it goes,
can I have some of that?
So we gave him some and then we went back to
Epilito his house and the cab drivers spent all his money on coke there and we
smoked freebase all night long to the next morning.
And the cab driver went home broke.
How will you still healthy?
I was a healthy.
How are you right now?
Still healthy with all this,
all the freebies.
All the crud.
I only did it for two,
two or three years.
That's it.
Yeah.
But it was a long,
two or three years.
Two or three years or fucking,
you know,
two or three if you're lucky,
you fucking got out of that because how many people do we know that did it for a
long time and they're just dead.
Their nervous system is just shocked too on how many people who like were really
in coke.
Like that was one of the speculations about Robin with Parkinson's.
I don't know if there's a direct correlation between Parkinson's and cocaine
use,
but there was one of the speculations that I'd read that like Robin was like a
famous guy for doing a lot of coke and he'd done it for a long time.
It struggled back and forth with addiction,
uh,
but that,
see neurological disorders and cocaine's it could be somehow or another
connected,
willing to king.
Did you ever just clean Robin in a coke addict?
Like me?
Robin always had money so he could get as much coke as he fucking want.
I didn't have money so I couldn't get,
you know,
I was 40,
$50 a night or hearing and you know what I mean,
or whatever.
I think he was,
he was a giant movie star,
right?
Yeah.
I mean he was,
that was like during the Popeye days.
Right.
Fucking garb and fucking,
you know,
fucking money and saving money and you know,
and when you got that same wood prior fucking prior,
you know,
cooking that they have fucking ounces.
I'm cooking up a half a gram or a gram and fucking looking to do hand jobs,
whatever.
Just,
oh.
But his dream was to work rascals and I think he finally got it,
that he was booked there and it was somewhere on the road working and he got a
pain and he got a stone or something,
a kidney or gallstone
that broke through his stomach or something.
And he passed away that right before he was going to do headline rascal.
Ah,
you know,
and that was,
there wasn't a lot of TV.
He,
he's,
he's no,
a video of him online.
I looked for it.
The,
there's,
he was apparently in comedies.
Dirtiest doesn't,
but it's not available.
It's not available on Youtube.
Well,
there was something he came from knows him,
knows there was long island acts,
you know Hawthorne and
Bob Nelson.
There was a lot of those good guys.
How spear there was a lot of,
then there's nothing,
there's no video for him.
For Bob Boyd as weird when a good guy,
he really was so nice to me.
Was He showing nice to me?
He used to,
he just was nice and he was a headliner and I always knew when he would just be,
you know what I mean?
Well there was a lot of those guys back then that we're a regional guys that
were like uh,
like everybody loved like famous,
like the auto and George type guys.
They were like sorta regional too that you know like the northeast.
Yeah.
Fucking Otto the best stories.
But he was the,
Otto was a sweetheart.
He's a great guy.
Very,
very nice guy sweetheart.
Yeah,
there was a lot of,
I mean I don't know what's a lot of assholes.
The best thing that ever happened to a stand up comedy in New York.
There was two things.
One was Collin's tough crowd cause everybody got to see all those guys together
shooting the shit.
And uh,
you remember when Geraldo got into it with Denis leary tortured him all.
It was so beautiful.
Everybody was like,
yes.
And he didn't even go far enough.
No.
I mean he was really kind like what he did.
But if you've ever seen that,
it's one of the most telling pull up Greg Geraldo versus Denis leary on tough
crowd.
I'd love tough crowd.
I was so bummed out when that show was canceled.
It was when it was canceled to me it was like almost like my divorce.
That's how I felt.
Yeah,
it was a,
it was a real tough blow.
But the other thing is ona,
ONA was fucking fantastic,
man.
Ona was fantastic because ONA was like the first time they had a show where I'm
such a dummy,
I wrote comedy,
dirtiest desert
and uh,
for whatever reason doesn't,
doesn't,
um,
iTunes couldn't recognize it.
Um,
I dunno.
It's just,
just an awesome time.
What do you call it?
That Geraldo Dennis
hilarity thing though,
you got to respect.
And as silly for the fact that I thought that was much more,
I hadn't seen that in years.
That was brutal.
I'm sorry ladies and gentlemen,
if you listen to this while,
well,
if I could go back in time and give you five minutes,
I would.
Well,
the problem was we listened to too much before it.
If we just heard that from where he started to the fight there,
but the what you miss out is how mad Dennis
got.
Like when he like you don't talk to me like that.
Like his face.
Like who the fuck are you?
Put Your Rabo is a funny fucking dude who was in accomplish comedian too.
He's a real comic.
Yeah.
I mean he's not wearing sunglasses on a fucking TV show.
That's what Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
if you're not,
if you're not black and you were in sunglasses on a TV show,
go fuck yourself.
I would say black guys get a pass was gonna pass line guys,
famous black guy like Floyd Mayweather.
Wear sunglasses on a TV show.
I go,
okay,
I get it.
Floyd Mayweather.
It's different community.
But if you're a white guy,
you got sunglasses on a TV show,
fuck off.
So what you're saying is you're not big fan.
I'm racist.
I'm racist towards,
towards black guys.
I prefer them.
I give them special leeway.
I'm good friend.
Um,
I,
I'll take black eyes over most white people.
Well it's just,
it's a different thing.
I Dunno why,
but it just is,
you know,
she a black eye.
That's a famous guy on award shows with sunglasses on it.
It doesn't bother me unless it's Kanye and I'm like,
come on dude,
take those fuckers.
You haven't,
you've suffered enough.
I'll take her gay black over a gay white any day more funny.
You think,
wait my mind as comics or,
and it wasn't human.
I take gay,
gay,
black sounds too.
And it goes to the extreme.
It's too,
it's,
it's too gay.
It's adorable and hilarious,
but it's like,
it's a whole nother level.
Like when,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I mean,
shearers gay,
black and Shiri skylight.
Why?
What are you talking about?
He knows what I'm talking about.
Talking.
No one knows who they are.
They all know,
you know,
I've talked with the flamboyant,
uh,
they're more flamboyant and some generalized,
you know,
it's tough,
but you already did gay blacks would fuck
you started this whole thing.
I'm pro black.
I am too.
I give them the leeway to wear the glasses.
It's what I call white people on it.
What,
why people were not allowed to wear glasses.
Especially,
you know,
that's the other thing,
like a comic that gets to like fashion conscious.
It's like we were talking about Russell and his crazy fucking jacket and I love
Russell,
but I'm glad you called them on it because otherwise he would've wore that twice
a fucking whore.
Fucking horrible jacket.
Let me tell you,
Jesus,
I fucking rather,
where do you Bola fucking horrible.
Uh,
hey.
How many poor people will die to that shit.
Is that,
is that over?
They contain that stuff still in the papers are showing dead bodies and all
that.
Oh,
what a fucking terrible way to go.
I've been reading on Ebola,
like what it is like,
what the effects are,
the hemorrhagic effects.
I can't read on diseases.
Don't fucking give you a break.
You out your free [inaudible].
Yeah,
it freaks
me the fuck out because there's people that are going over there that are
helping,
you know,
like a aids workers and stuff and they come back and they're fucked up with the
Ebola.
There's been a two of them so far that have been delivered to the United States
that are,
that have Ebola and whether or not they make it's touch and go,
you know.
Well I think they let one out of the hospital now,
but I'm saying,
you know,
once you get it,
I think that the,
uh,
the expectancy is like 40%,
40% death expectancy.
Jesus fucking Gary Man.
And what is it?
And this has nothing to do,
but they're all coming from Africa.
These fucking
sanitation,
the of,
there's a lot of issues.
Biodiversity,
I'm sure jungles
thinking that once you have,
you can't get it again or is that a good question?
Which takes super doctors.
Well that's what a vaccine.
You can't get it again cause you're dead.
It's just Chi.
I was just in buffalo in this open miker had the funniest bit about the Ebola
virus and it was an open,
no,
he may be a five year comic.
It was so fun.
I wish I knew his name so I could show you his name.
But he said,
uh,
they just brought two doctors back with the Ebola virus.
He goes,
thank God they were white because I hate to be at the airport yelling,
go back to Africa.
If they weren't
Aha to fuck.
How clever and funny.
That's a good joke.
You know.
I knew a dude.
There was a comic years ago.
This is how fucking shit.
I'm a hypochondria.
He fucking died of meningitis.
Jerry red wheels.
Cabriolet wrongs.
Yeah.
Did you know him?
He's a great guy.
He's very,
very well.
Yeah,
it was a great car.
And when you get meningitis,
you can't touch your chin to your chest because your spine swells up into back.
Ooh,
really?
So for a week I thought I had meningitis and I'm fucking walking around like
this and people are looking at me like,
like,
I'm fucking nuts.
Can you had it for a week and you didn't go to a doctor?
No,
I just,
in my head I'm going,
oh,
what if I had this,
let me check.
I didn't think I,
you know,
I mean I go there and I will do that and maybe it was two days,
but I'm a comic so I exaggerated a little,
sorry.
Sorry for fucking really,
maybe it was probably an hour or maybe it was just walking to fucking blocks.
I don't fucking know.
All right,
it's three hours.
I can't be on fucking point every second.
So I went like this and ash,
why I don't read,
you know,
people walking by going,
oh,
I think,
I think he,
you know,
we think he thinks he has meningitis because what else was said?
You know what I'm saying?
But I can't read that shit cause I get fucking,
you know,
hypochondriac.
You just,
when you get older you start to think,
well what the fuck?
I look at the Ige.
Oh,
I got to have some tin.
It's the fucking odds.
How healthy are you?
Like,
as far as like what you eat and I exercise.
Oh,
I don't,
I haven't had red meat and probably 23 years I fucking,
I work,
I don't do cardio.
I got to steal my kids gave me this fitbit thing,
you know,
it tells you how many calories and how many steps you take and what,
which uh,
it's no different than a mirror.
Uh,
you know,
cause that'll tell you whether you're fucking fat slob.
But I wear a watch also,
which is weird.
Well,
they'll fit bits and I wear a watch.
It's got a watch on it.
No,
no,
there's no watch on a fitbit.
Oh,
I thought there was no,
it was just,
it's,
it's a bunch of different ones.
Oh,
they do have one jeweled watch.
Yeah.
So,
but I mean,
I,
I work out,
I lift in my hotel,
like I buy,
like if there's no workout room,
there's no workout room where I'm staying.
There's just cardio.
So I got shit I bought,
I got this one fucking day.
What's that?
Uh,
what's it called?
I one that you can put it in your door.
Fucking do,
you know,
I do back and I'll do arms,
chest.
Then I also got a good tricep.
Well No,
I love how he can't just tell you he does backs and arm and chest.
He has to stand up and start mining the motions as if no one's ever done a lat
pull down before.
He's like I do back and I do buy,
I do chest,
give us a sign language.
I like,
I'm a little animated today on the show.
So I try to be fucking healthy.
I mean Bonnie and I,
Donny,
what a fucking half of keeps me Benny.
I say that's who I don't have friends.
So I talk about my wife.
Did your wife's cool?
What we should on New Year at one time we sit on New Year's Eve.
This one she ate meat.
Uh,
uh,
New Year's day we're going to go to KFC cause we probably haven't been here in
20 fucking years.
Tenure.
So we went New Year's day and we ate there and our bodies couldn't fucking
handle it.
Really got so,
yeah,
it was,
it's so good.
But it just,
if you haven't eaten that,
the batter and all that stuff and all that stuff,
and I'm a pig,
you know,
so I'm fucking eating and just fucking taste so fucking,
but next thing you know,
I fucking sick and delirious and you know what I mean?
So that only lasted one new year's day and holding average 57
wow.
You look good man.
He looked real good for 57 you're taking your shirt off for me.
Oh,
that's awful.
Nice.
Pukes Bro.
She showed me his shave stomach
baffled while we have lift,
bro.
What's that?
Do I even left yet?
Do you even lift?
Yeah,
we're fight.
Fuck.
I know I took online thing.
That fucking guy guy goes up to the series of God and he'll deal.
Do you even lift bro?
And then films?
It's like a prank.
I,
here's the thing,
I have to lose 10 pounds for what?
You can't have dish many tattoos and not be ripped.
Oh,
you need to lose body fat.
Yeah.
You gotta be,
you gotta be fucking rip my eye.
I said I don't have.
Yeah.
Then what about the guy from Buck Cherry?
Actually he,
he but he's skinny.
He's skinny.
Okay.
Well there's some fat guys that have awesome tattoos.
Dude from MTV.
Matt,
the Bald Guy,
but who looks cooler?
But I said,
I don't know who that is.
I said this on,
on a,
on my podcast I want to do,
I want to Hoshin outside comedy festival where I get to do it in my shirt off
outside.
You want to do comedy with your shirt off?
Do you think that'd be funnier that way?
It'd be cool.
Like a rock be cool.
It'd be like a fucking he come now.
No.
Okay.
Different rules.
Whoo.
No,
no.
It doesn't enhance.
It doesn't,
it's having a six pack.
Does it enhance your comedy?
Probably takes away from it.
You know,
a
guy can dream,
you know,
now it's just not a good dream.
Let it go.
I hosted should Woodstock 99 did you really?
Yeah.
Fucking what was that like?
Oh,
she's fucking amazing.
How many bands?
I did three days.
Two or three stages.
So it was the east stage,
the maniacs to biggest limp biscuit.
Then the west stage and then they had the alternative stage.
So I was on the West stage and it was like buck shower.
He was at my,
I had a fight with the lead singer on,
well,
I didn't know who I like,
it had just one trail.
We stayed in and a big part of the trailer,
which for the bands before they went on.
Then I had just a little room with a chair.
So I walk into the room and um,
I have a cigarette.
I smoked at the time and some guys in my room,
he goes,
can you put it out?
I go,
go fuck yourself.
This is my trailer.
I didn't know who he was.
Right.
And he just huffed and puffed and walked out.
Then I realized when I saw him on stage,
he was the lead singer to punk Sherry.
I'm going,
this is the hottest,
best fucking band here.
These fucking guys are great.
Right,
right.
So I ended up buying a CD when I got home or did he never speak to you?
I never saw him again,
but I think he know I saw him that day.
I saw him at the,
uh,
at the food tent and he apologized.
He goes,
Hey,
I'm sorry for,
you know,
size.
And I said,
I was too,
cause like,
you know,
I'm in recovery and you got to,
do I have,
I'm sorry I was an asshole.
I didn't know who you were.
And he said he was sorry.
But anyhow,
so I was bringing it up on my stage,
uh,
who,
Mickey Hart playing the trumpet.
Metallica.
Megadeath uh,
you know,
this was 99.
Who else was on my stage?
It was just,
so you're doing standup too?
Well,
I'm just,
I'm just hosting it and I'll do some crowd work,
you know,
fuck around.
And you know,
at one point I had,
there was maybe 50,000 and I had them all yell at one time.
I go,
I want you to say hi to my kids so I can record it.
So I had them all,
y'all,
Hi Jessica Than Hi Ellen.
You know,
so I had that on tape.
Oh,
I had like 50,000 people yell,
Hi Jessica.
Hi.
Cool.
And I got to tape at home.
And then it was,
you know,
go out some announcements and then you bring up some bands.
Some I did some,
you know,
they just came up.
Uh,
our mother piece was on my stage.
There was a bunch a ice ice cube was on my stage and uh,
there was a lot of cool bands and Mickey Hart and plan and trunk,
those fucking dudes killed.
Uh,
Bruce Hornsby was on my,
so they asked me Hornsby.
Yeah.
Who's that old dude that's wavy gravy
money in the bank.
Great.
If I remember,
wasn't Wavy Gravy,
just the guy,
but he was popular for doing so much acid back in the day.
Like can,
we were like,
oh we got to do as much acid as this guy
is.
It's a big acid guy.
Grateful favor and say,
hold on to my two little daughters.
Get together Alan on the count of three one.
That's cool.
Look at the size of the ants out there.
Look at that.
What does that look at?
That it's always a weird thing when someone read,
does big cultural event like that?
Where'd you find you?
Like,
how did it get out of my closet?
I'm feeling good.
How was your a copy of that copy?
Are you guys having fun?
Your voice sounds so different.
Is that because you were smoking back then after three days?
Oh,
I see.
Was this the mud baby year with all the,
she was to fight fire with fire.
The main stage,
those are fire.
The last night they started riding because of a water and,
oh no,
the water.
What?
There was no water
that I don't care.
What
were you saying?
There was a fire.
What don't you remember when they looked at fires over on the main stage?
The last day it got wild and they started like lighting fires,
but they were,
they were mad because there was no water for like $7 a piece and
there was no public water.
There was no like waterfowl in or anything like that.
No,
it's a fucking in the field is,
there's outhouses that were disgusting.
I mean I had a hotel room,
but uh,
how many fucking people there were?
Oh,
just fucking amazing.
You'd look if you look up to fires fired at 99 but that was the main stage.
And that stage brother Weise from Rochester and Tom Papa,
we're hosting that stage and they never got to really say anything because he's
a radio bang guy up in Rochester.
Yeah.
Show.
They asked me do you want to do to eat each stage a main one?
I said,
no fucking way am I going there.
You know,
I didn't have in three days one thing thrown at me.
Okay.
Which is amazing at a fucking,
you know when there's that many people,
that's a pretty amazing,
those guys were having bottles strong.
Okay.
Because they were just so rowdy at that stage.
Limp Bizkit that stage had,
so you were at a better stage.
Isn't it crazy that you were there?
There's 50,000 people where you were and that's not even the big stage.
No,
that's insane.
Wow.
Red Hot Chili peppers.
Yeah,
they weren't.
That was the thing,
clay,
and this is probably not a good idea,
dude.
Just going to get us pool from youtube playing music.
Right?
Isn't that how it works?
It recognizes music.
Oh
Shao I mean,
it was the coolest thing because,
uh,
you know,
I had van,
we were taking,
we stayed in the casino,
the turning point and how to decide,
you know,
I met some hot girl.
I go,
look man,
I got a place if you want to take a shower or something,
you know,
fucking hand job for a shower.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
and I brought rd Fuqua with me.
Like I asked a bunch of people and they couldn't do it,
you know,
so odd.
He came already like,
he had a great timing.
We're eating and you know how you eat in a tent with all the free food and all
year,
I'm shitting next to fucking like major,
like corn.
And I'm just,
you're shooting with these fucking guys and online with them getting food.
You know,
I was in a,
in a van with a,
Ah,
I forget the band,
the lead singer to a band.
I never know.
I go,
what are you doing here?
He goes,
I'm in,
I'm playing.
I go name of the band.
And I had no clue what I want,
but there were fucking famous,
well,
I'm glad you don't remember.
Again,
I know the story.
All the more awesome.
Or
I remember I met a guy who was famous,
Asco who you were,
he told me I forgot,
but he was famous.
I stink.
I have some good stories.
He's lucky.
Yes.
Fading a little.
We're about two hours and 15 minutes,
so I'm fucking juvenate Qa right now.
A little bit of a wall.
Which doc thing was kind of fucking cool.
Well it was getting them all to say hi to your kids.
It's fucking awesome.
We can talk about the movie coming out.
Yeah,
that's what I want to talk about.
Yeah.
We want to talk about your movie called women aren't funny and it was you guys,
you're motivated to do it,
uh,
by the Christopher Hitchens famous thing that he wrote and actually did a video
about it as well.
Right?
I don't know.
You wrote in the Vanity Fair,
which is,
yeah,
he wrote it.
And then he also did a video where he described why women aren't funny because
they don't need to be because men are pursuing them.
And the reason why men become funny is he gave us sort of an evolutionary
viewpoint of why women aren't,
it's a defense mechanism for men and times and it's an offensive mechanism to
for men,
you know?
Yeah.
She laid it gets you out of fights,
but obviously it's not correct.
I mean,
we just watched him to Tasha Ligero destroy,
you know,
we watch Amy Schumer it,
there's a lot of funny
women.
Your wife is one of them.
Your wife is fucking hilarious.
Bonnie Mcfarlane,
I've known her for 20 years at least I've known him for at least 20 years,
maybe more.
She's funny as shit.
Here's the trail,
but I want the eyes.
But with more like mechanics,
I've heard women are almost as often as you're not planning.
That's in the shot.
Can you make me look something like that's not funny.
Funny.
Are you that for money to bed?
Everybody's fine.
It doesn't matter if you're a nine or Brian on one day.
You want me to get in the mall?
Ah,
shit that she old trailer.
You've got to get to good trailer.
Okay.
Where was the iTunes?
Go to iTunes woman.
I'm funny.
And the trailer.
That was good.
Anyway,
so tell us about this movie and try to be,
um,
I mean you,
you,
you have this thing,
you set it up where you're doing these,
uh,
you're doing standup and you're going on the road.
Then you're interviewing all these people as well while you're doing it.
Well,
here it started Bonnie,
this was Bonnie.
Bonnie wrote an article and checking magazine about women,
Kamiyah satire and a lot of women on how women's stink.
And then it was all saying,
you know,
and then the Christopher Hitchens article came out and you know,
we had so much going on in our careers,
but then,
you know,
careers,
they go up and down.
It was a mall.
We said,
you know,
we've got a door on fucking project we've had fucking pilots to keep,
they're not getting picked up.
You know,
we did two,
I did three Po,
two Polish would hurt and me and Patricia did a pilot then for pilots weren't
picked up.
I'm going,
we've got to do our own fucking thing,
you know,
so she goes,
well let's make this movie woman you know about female comics,
you know,
show.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
and we had no,
we didn't know what the fuck we were in a car.
We're thinking that these bitch set will be in the movie and we're not even
close to ever making a boat,
you know,
hey,
we'll do this,
we'll do that.
And then our first comic,
we got like one or two,
you know,
just like Cory Kahaney.
Well what was the idea behind it?
You were just going to interview different female subject
if we were going to interview him on that subject and also videotape us.
Right.
And what was the,
what were you trying to achieve?
We are trying to achieve,
okay.
It's the question we are trying to make a funny movie because of a female to
making a funny movie or sheer answer.
Let him finish what you're saying.
Go ahead.
There's your answer.
Okay.
Because there's no a woman,
funny as a matter of fucking opinion,
but no one ever says,
you know,
uh,
people will go up to women comics,
90% of time we go,
I don't,
I hate women comics,
but you were funny,
you know,
no one ever goes up to a black comic goes,
look,
I hate black comics,
but you are fun.
That sounds exactly what the dollar would say,
but you know what I'm saying?
And,
and show her vision
was a lot to my vision was,
fuck,
I gotta get rejuvenate his career,
getting a jumpstart it somehow,
you know,
besides what I was doing it,
I went a and putting out CDs and doing whatever teenagers objective was to show
that it's ridiculous so that when it was just so ridiculous fucking point and
Christopher Hitchens racist article and no body is,
you know,
uh,
we challenge it,
challenge it or like a re re bottle,
whatever.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go,
let's see.
The,
the thing,
let's play it.
Here's the,
here's the new one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's recording.
Yes it is.
Do you think women are?
There's more funny guys that I went to high school with or like mechanics.
I'm female comedian Bonnie Mcfarlane and I've heard women aren't funny almost as
often as you're not funny.
Kitchens blows my mind.
I mean I just think like,
can you imagine if someone was like,
are black people smart for Vanity Fair?
Like you,
you guys scoot all over the place and it just,
it gets spooked.
I don't know.
Whenever people are like sexist towards women,
I just get super racist towards black people become comedians because they were
molested as introvert recruit to me as a female leader.
But comedy is this,
get a job.
I can't do this anymore.
So many great actresses,
Richard Ready Actresses Richard have a great
guess what?
That was a male comics.
Come on,
let's go.
This is stupid.
Can I do something stupid?
What do you try it?
It looks like you're doing a butter commercial or something.
You were asking the right person cause I think a lot of guys and not that fine.
Everybody's fine.
It doesn't matter if you're a guy or girl,
are you have money to bed?
I am.
It's funny,
I'm not wearing any pants
Larry.
This is Sarah does exactly what it shoots it.
She planned that on purpose.
No,
actually what I was telling you,
which that wasn't a joke.
Oh.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
I need the big toe is longer but it's self.
The pick those longer after it.
But how funny.
That's what I was telling you to Diana.
Yeah.
I thought maybe that was a plant like watching that.
Oh I just so not at all.
It's just so funny.
Like show Bonnie,
you know Bonnie wanted to direct a movie.
You know she's fucking,
she's had another level when it comes to writing a vision,
I'm telling you,
I've never seen anybody any like,
she just did an article and they wanted to write five of our favorite male
comics,
but she didn't,
she wrote five but not why they're funny.
But why,
you know,
like I,
I told her to put Jelly d ice in it.
Like you'll see Joey,
eh,
but it was funny stuff cause her funny because I like him as a woman because he
seems like the kind of guy that will hold me,
you know what I mean?
So she just took it to a different perspective than
they asked her and they loved it so she,
her mind works.
So she had this vision for a movie and we started off,
you know,
interviewing whoever,
we got can,
we didn't know we got this cameraman here,
this cameraman there and no experience whatsoever.
None whatsoever.
Dan,
we got,
I don't know if our,
for if our biggest,
first,
our first biggest guy,
we got Chris,
we got Chris Rock.
I said,
Chris,
would you do you know?
He said,
yeah.
So we interviewed him at the cellar.
So once we got Chris,
then we started getting,
we started getting other people,
you know what that video made me want to do,
made,
made me want to see you interviewed Dan Cook for like an hour and find out how
crazy he must be.
We think we did an interview on for like 45 minutes to an hour.
That was what the weirdest part of the video was.
I wanted him to elaborate a little what?
Everybody's funny that that's one of the craziest things anybody's ever said.
Whether it's an not every day,
all day.
You got to see what he says.
He after it.
What does everybody want?
Funny.
What are you teasing me here?
People see your goddamn movie.
You don't have to leave a tease like that.
Oh,
and a doe and a,
they don't anymore.
Well,
women or I don't exactly remember.
He goes,
everybody's knife.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
that's what he thought.
What he thought it out of context is that they all know exactly like he said.
Does he say that women aren't funny?
No.
He said in the beginning,
let me,
I can,
I don't remember.
Let's just end this.
Okay,
now hold on.
What's the cause?
One day,
a cup of coffee or something and something happens and you two hours
all be fucking fine and you want to know
what's holding your hand the whole way.
And it was still very slippery road.
You guys are holding here.
First of all,
there's three of you fucking guys against me.
I'm done helping kind of,
and you're laughing.
Listen to me.
If it came down to what they got your back,
uh,
the bottom line is,
Dane said,
what?
He fucking said.
That's the bottom line.
Danes.
He said,
boy,
that's a window.
Remember we take we fucking four years ago,
why would you know?
I mean,
you're pitching it.
Can I move on?
And people were going,
you got to do Rogan.
And now they're thinking,
I'm fucking bombing.
I had some really good lines and stories I've told about it was great.
Now we're not fucking around.
So he said,
I think,
what did he say?
Everything.
Everybody's funny till I started seeing some female comics,
I'm going,
Whoa,
some of these girls aren't funny.
What she said.
Who was the,
which was the chick that said,
uh,
if,
like vanity fair writing a thing or black guy,
smart priest,
Chelsea Peretti,
Chelsea,
she's fucking hilarious.
He kills you.
She does.
She's killed.
Shot the movie.
So now we get Chris.
And so now we're starting to get other fucking,
you know,
we go,
hey,
you know,
can you do this?
Can you do this?
And you know,
Denny,
after Chris,
we get,
you know,
uh,
joy bay,
harsh Susie Essman,
uh,
you know,
with don and Judy goal and Hickson's dies while you're doing this.
Hitchins die.
Did he have cancer while you guys were filming it?
We didn't know if he did.
We didn't know about it.
No,
because we filmed,
we started this project,
this August is seven years old.
It took us four years to film because we film for three years and then we went
into editing and then we went,
we sent it to somebody goes,
this is what you have to do to make this movie work.
So we went and reshot then we got Adam Carolla after Hitchens and Hitchins sins
died.
And we got Adam Carolla.
And so we had another year of filming and then a couple of years of fucking
illegal with lawyers.
We went through three different lawyers pull out Christopher Hitchens,
right?
Why women still aren't funny.
It's a video.
It's from Vanity Fair.
And uh,
he made a video about the same article that he wrote.
And the first,
the first,
the first comment is what a narrow minded,
frustrated,
misogynistic man.
And he's not even funny.
He obviously feels threatened by women and by his potential inability to get
laid,
which of course is the most important thing for evolution.
Also read this
video,
Bro Video.
There's a video,
Brian.
Um,
so we can hear it instead of just showing it right.
Why women are still not,
yeah.
Why women still aren't funny.
It's on youtube.
It's kind of funny.
I mean,
it is funny.
It's,
it's interesting like the,
uh,
the whole argument is very interesting.
That argument about why women are funny,
why men are fun and you know,
it's like,
you don't know why anything is funny.
It's just funny.
There's people,
like perfect example is like I've always said,
Mitch Hedberg,
if you saw him,
Mitch Hedberg on writing,
you would never think it's funny.
If you saw it on paper,
you'd like them.
What does that,
that's nonsense.
But it's funny.
She,
and why is it funny?
Cause he,
it was indefensible.
He was too funny.
He was too smart.
Smart.
I mean,
he goes,
you have to,
I mean,
he went after her Mother Teresa.
He,
you know,
he goes,
you have to,
well,
he covered all those bases with his essay too.
If you read the essay,
he's not saying it's impossible for women to be funny.
That's what Patrice says.
Yeah.
But we had Derosa we took it out and put them in the extras play fucking,
uh,
Hitchens for one scene,
you know,
and Derosa played Hitchens.
We have it in the,
at the end,
in the credits.
It's so fucking funny.
I bought him a corncob pipe and an ascot.
So he's sitting there with it.
But to Rosie came self,
he had not flood.
He was doing the accent and he was going,
you know,
you're,
you're basically just what you're here to get fucked.
Okay.
That's why you're on the planet.
And it was so fucking funny is you get to that
online.
Is that going to be
a part of the iTunes version?
It's in the,
it's in the movie.
Yeah.
It's when the credits are rolling.
Ah,
it's just a,
it's a row.
So it's not an extras.
It's just,
we didn't go around,
so like I should run,
shall we got this,
you know,
we're starting to get bigger racks,
we can only come to la once or twice.
And when we came to La,
we got Sarah,
Wanda,
Todd glass and Maria Bamford.
And that was all we could get.
And at the time we turned down a battery goes,
you want Whitney Cummings?
So we don't know.
We didn't know who she was or like fucking idiots at the time.
She had no heat.
Isn't that incredible?
That was just a couple of years ago.
But,
so,
and then we'd go back to New York.
We get joy bay harsh,
Susie Essman.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
and some,
pretty decent Joan Rivers.
We get Joan.
When Joan was great,
she sat with Bonnie,
then we got Rita Rudner Rosie.
So then the illegal work,
you know,
and I went through three lawyers,
which it took a lot of time,
which was a nightmare.
And now it's fucking on.
And it's so,
it's so fucking funny.
We showed it in four festivals.
It killed in every fucking festival.
Bonnie took 60 hours of tape,
60 fucking hours,
transcribed everything,
watch everything and turned it into a 80 minute movie.
Wow.
How long?
It took a couple of years.
I mean,
would the editors in all by herself and it,
well,
no,
she,
yeah.
And then she would take it to the editor and s and sat on top of them.
And then our first editor,
we went to a new editor after that and had to re edited again.
We shot it on four different cameras.
So then we had to take her to post works and have it all synchronized,
whatever the technical term is to make it look like it's from one camera.
So that you know,
took however long and another 15,000 real labor of love for you guys.
Yeah.
But,
and it's not about,
look,
the money's gone.
If I get money back,
it's found money,
but it's just we did it ourselves.
How many Cros to do?
If you had to guess?
I,
I'm not allowed to say.
Really?
Yeah,
she said don't say
okay.
Sorry.
I asked.
Uh,
I'll tell you the way it looks like.
It looks awesome.
You sent me a copy.
I haven't watched it,
but it's sitting at home on my,
uh,
my area.
I haven't watched a DVD in about a year.
So this would be the first DVD that I watch.
Well,
you like,
you should know what,
do everybody in it.
That's why,
you know what I mean?
I'll just buy it on iTunes.
When's it going to be out?
It comes up for preorder now,
but it comes out Tuesday,
Tuesday to 26.
Okay,
so soon.
So next Tuesday.
Next Tuesday.
The 26 women aren't funny.
I'll make sure I get,
I'm going to definitely get it on iTunes in a matter of fact,
I'm not going to watch it until I get it because I'm on a one year streak with
no DVDs.
I don't want to break it.
I'm not totally on a one year street cause I still to put them in for my kids.
So I've actually used your DVD player.
I mean you could take that DVD if maybe you know at a Weinstein.
No,
I don't know anybody.
I don't know anybody in show business.
I'm very down.
Come in here.
Nope,
nobody does.
I'm very happy.
I'm totally out of the acting filmmaking television show loop completely.
I might as well be working as an optometrist cause I'm not that smart.
I might as well be a mechanic.
Don't you interview them?
Don't take,
come in.
I mean I though I'd have them in.
Sure.
I mean I don't know that you have like a fucking big fucking a great podcast.
Does it?
I mean,
look,
I would love to have Harvey Weinstein on cause he's a bad motherfucker and I
think it'd be interesting to talk to them.
I mean the guy has been responsible for the greatest movies ever,
but I'm interested in whatever interesting people I can meet,
whoever I can meet that I can have on and talk to about anything.
It doesn't have to be like a guy that's show business related at all.
Matter of fact,
a lot of times I prefer when it's not,
you know,
I preferred unique things.
So I,
I'm curious about a bunch of different shit.
I'm not that serious about movie making,
you know,
it's not that I like watching him watching more crack shorty.
Fuck yeah.
I love a good crack story.
You weren't with Otto when there's the famous auto crack store where they picked
up this club owner's daughter and they took her into the city and auto stopped
off at some park to get crack and he smoked it in the car and everybody's
freaking out.
And uh,
they called them up.
They go,
oh,
what the fuck are you doing?
He goes,
what?
I thought the broad wanted a potty.
It's a famous story.
She's in the car with him and everybody was like,
well,
you're fucking smoking crack in the car.
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you a good story.
You'll love this.
I've tell it all the time and I feel bad for the guy,
but fuck it.
Okay.
So was the names to protect the,
I'll say the name,
it's,
you know,
fucking bow shade again.
Show I'm doing one night or me and bashed steel.
Frankie's a heroin.
I love Frankie Frankie's a heroin addict and I'm a [inaudible] and I'm a
freebase adding.
So we're doing a one nighter.
We have to pick up this act in New York.
Right?
Uh,
and he did,
he didn't come to the one night or with us and we'll drop him off.
So we do the one nighter and we're taking them back to the Improv and we go a,
hold on,
we've got to make a couple stops first.
You know,
and it's just some little white kid.
So I go up to Spanish Harlem,
it's like 168th and Amsterdam.
Believe me,
this is fucking not the area this kid has ever fucking seen in his life ever.
Right,
right.
I think I was up here going up to a one time and I got out of the car,
I was with these other comics and this dude was chasing another deal with a
knife and they,
these comics go get back in the car and I go,
fuck,
he's not after me.
It's not my beef.
I don't give a fuck.
And I went and it's so was that kind of area.
So we take the kid up there and then he goes,
can you fucking please drop me off at the Improv?
I cannot,
you know,
and we got one more stop and we go down to the,
to alphabet city and Frankie cops heroin.
Now the kids are fucking mess now.
Frankie's in the back seat shooting up right as I'm driving.
Oh my God.
And the kid is a fucking,
he's going,
he's losing his fucking mind.
It's don't get me the fuck Outta here.
You know,
I just cop crack and Frankie shooting dope in the back seat and we drop him off.
And it was David Spade.
He just came to New York.
There's some average and layer.
He's from Arizona.
He's from Phoenix who said he had props.
He did prompts.
He didn't prompts,
he had prompts.
I mean I was doing it for me three years.
He was doing it for maybe one or two or maybe three.
We all stunk.
Frankie was decent.
He was framing was good.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and it was him.
It was just some little white kid.
And he was like,
get me the fuck Outta here.
And he's met enough in the backseat and I told the story a million times on
radio,
but I told it on cow head in Florida and uh,
didn't spade was on county.
It goes to any comics that were holding you like hot fucking Boston.
Bastiaan they fucking took me against my will.
That's hilarious.
Well,
opie and Anthony was in my opinion,
the best show ever for standup comics,
like the best show ever to have like a POW wow.
Because we would be on me and I've been on with you before with like how many
people we've been on like five,
six guys.
And it just becomes this crazy round table with everybody shooting the shit.
And that's what encouraged me to do podcasts was doing ona.
I mean it was a bunch of things,
but one of them was Anthony's live from the compound.
That was the biggest one.
Uh,
seeing Anthony in front of that green screen when he first started doing that.
And I was like,
this fucking guy just created a set in his house and he's just doing his own
thing like on the Internet for a goof.
It was like on a lot.
What does it,
do you remember what he had it on?
I think it was always on either Justin TV or some,
well that was us three.
It was something else.
It was like lives something.
They still use it pow talk and no,
it wasn't pal talk,
but he was doing pal.
Talk to,
cause the other thing about Anthony,
he was doing pal talk,
which is a lot like Ustream and they were doing it live from the studio so you
could see a video version of the show,
but then Tom Green off.
So when we went to his studio yet for that.
Yeah,
it's been tough.
Yeah.
Tom Green had a fucking full studio in his house.
His house had been trapped,
but he really had done it like,
it wasn't a podcast.
It was,
he had a television show on the Internet,
but he was doing it like a television show and he had his own servers.
Like he had these wires,
he's like snake wires through the fucking house and he'd converted his entire
living room.
It's like the tonight show said it was really weird.
Camera's there and everything.
It was really fucking fun.
That was one of them.
That was a big one.
Was it doing well?
Was it getting a,
it was a little ahead of its time.
He was really good at,
he was really good at it,
but it was ahead of its time.
It was before,
you know,
if he had done that today it would be gigantic.
It does now.
Well he does it again,
right?
He's doing it in an access TV.
Right?
He's got a show,
he's got an an actual TV show.
But um,
they,
you know,
when he was doing and uh,
Anthony
was doing,
but then going on ONA and realizing like that ONA would just give you this free
form,
you know,
where everybody else had like a real structure.
Any other show that you did.
They had a real,
and they would never invite five comics to come in and just start brutalizing
each other on the air and take over the whole show.
But Ona,
we just sit back and let it all happen.
They would just,
they would direct the Q and Anthony's a good light was a great laugh for and
shows up.
But if Patrice was on a run,
like no one tried to stop it,
no one tried to get in the way of Patrice and Louie,
you know,
when people were on the run,
they were on the run.
And the thing about,
she like the differential between them and stern,
stern put you on and I've never touched her.
And Bonnie did a lunch and I'm not against,
it's just I'm in the O and a camp.
It's like you don't leave the Gambinos and go to the Colombo.
You know what I mean?
Even when they were off the air for two years,
I'm still with this family so I don't go over it,
you know,
so,
and he would put comics on during the news,
but ONA,
we'll put you on the whole.
And they were smart because they're doing 20 hours of fucking radio a week
started.
They got comics on and other big guests,
but to comics are so fucking funny.
You know?
I mean they would,
they were very selective about their fucking comic.
I remember when I first came on,
they came to see me at Caroline's and both of them and I,
and I had a good set.
So they brought me on and it took me a couple times on until they go,
okay,
this guy,
you know,
whatever.
I brought Patrice in.
I was the first one to bring Patrice and so I've,
I go,
you got a sheet is fucking dude.
Yeah.
That's the thing about,
Oh hey,
they'll let you bring guys in.
I brought in Ari,
I brought in Joey.
You know,
you could bring people in.
Yeah.
If date they'll take your word for the day.
Like you don't do anything because if they think you're trying to fucking
disastrous results.
We've had guys bring in people and we're like,
what the fuck has gone on here?
So guys would bring their girlfriend with no fucking announcement whatsoever,
but fuck out while they're no microphone was on them.
Answer questions.
Remember that?
Oh,
when they would do events,
I mean,
you know,
they had any w days for fucking 50 gallon drum challenge and just fucking bitch.
I mean it was fucking,
you know,
could be almost on the verge of wacky radio.
But it was,
it was,
but it was to an edge up look when they did the homeless shop and spray,
do you know what that bit was?
You know,
they'd go to the mall and give these homes,
you know,
we would run when and give homeless people like 300 bucks to go.
And it was just a madhouse and it would go to Lake Livingston Mall and you know,
and,
and I would be with like two homeless guys and get play by play with my guys and
then their guy.
And it was just unbelievable.
I tried to talk,
my homeless guys are spending his whole 300 on one on and one Louis Vuitton.
Ty.
What was funny about them too is they didn't have to do just bits.
No.
They can do anything they did.
They had wacky radio
gags.
But some of the best shows were just people hanging out.
Any,
listen,
I day fucking,
you know how we talked,
how great Jenny was.
Yeah.
This how great he was.
But they didn't give a fuck.
He came in the first time.
There's one,
they were in new and they wouldn't let him in studio.
They're gonna keep and they kept them at was a waiting room they had when they
were in a,
that had pinball machines on.
Right.
And they fuck with them.
What they made them do.
Yeah.
And He'd shut off.
He's fucking Richard,
Jenny,
but,
and they're fucking,
you know,
arrogant fucking hot fucking Radio Djs,
you know.
So there's,
there's tons,
there's a lot of ego from both sides.
So,
you know,
and they're funny fucking radio and he's a great comic.
So they had him out there.
There's pinball machines,
there's spirit,
whatever.
And they wouldn't let them in yet.
And they made him start off his interview through the window.
They call it,
they did a prison interview.
Like he had a talk through the window,
like it was a prison visit.
Oh,
that's so ridiculous that they would come back on.
Yeah.
And then I think they brought him in after that.
There was one that came back on during the XM days.
Right.
Was it years later he came back on that,
that guy hit me hard when that guy killed himself.
Yeah.
Yard.
That was,
that was one like,
whoa.
Oh,
well I just,
because we knew him as a friend or no,
I didn't know him as a friend.
I knew him as an acquaintance.
Like he was always friendly.
I had some conversations with them,
had a nice conversation with him on a plane just a little bit before he died.
He was sitting just by chance right in front of me and I was like,
what's up?
Rich was going on,
what are you doing?
He was out there doing some crazy corporate gig,
you know,
they would fly him out and give them like a hundred grand and he's,
he's ridiculous cakes and he was on his way doing that in the same town where I
was doing a club and we just talked a little bit and then,
you know,
a couple of weeks later I got the news and it was just,
that was hard for me,
man.
Yeah,
some of it was,
where's me?
When I,
when I first started,
that guy was like a huge influence and a,
I got to see him one time before I ever paid to see standup.
I remember he just murdered,
did it catch and Cambridge,
he was at catch a rising star in Cambridge and I went down to see him as,
he just fucking destroyed it.
He was machine gun.
It was so funny,
so good too.
I remember just sitting there and I was sitting in the front row and I was just
saying,
I'm like,
God damn like this.
I knew,
I knew I was seeing something special,
you know?
I mean I hadn't done comedy and I was thinking about doing it and I knew when I
saw him I was like,
wow,
this is,
I'm just so lucky that I could see this.
Cause I'd seen him on television before,
so I'm on the tonight show and I'd seen him I think on an HBO special or
something like that.
But to see him live like,
uh,
at,
at the comment at catch a rising star,
it was also just an amazing time for comedy,
you know,
because it was the time of the original Hbo Comedy Specials.
They really didn't exist before that.
There was like a series of started happening and those comedy specials gave
birth,
those,
those and the evening at the Improv and all those other shows gave birth to all
these great that came up.
And then all these comedy clubs because Steven Wright made it out of Boston.
Like,
did you ever see when standups stood out?
I'll make France Alamedo documentary.
It's about Boston.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
Talking me about that and it details when Steven Wright made it and when Steven
Wright made it,
everybody sort of freaked out and realize,
oh my God,
like not,
we're not just trying to be funny,
which is what everybody was before.
We're trying to make it and it changed the whole scene.
Let's scene kind of got weird.
Whereas before that it was all just a bunch of men,
savage men like Knox and like fucking Lenny Clarke and dawn Gavin and they were
getting hammered doing blow and fucking Taryn,
Taryn stages apart,
all cross the town crazy.
And it was so many clubs up care.
You were so mad.
I'd fucking one block.
There was five,
six duck Shoup comedy connection and there was another one comedy club that
Charles Play House,
which is upstairs.
It was in insane.
I remember working niche doing seven shows in one night upstairs,
downstairs to upstairs.
Downstairs.
It mix had three rooms.
There was three simultaneous shows going on at all times.
It was insane.
Then,
you know,
let me tell you,
you know who else I like Jenny,
but fucking dom,
I rarer,
rarer as a murderer.
He's a fucking,
I I'd want,
I stopped and cal and once it was just,
I mean,
I've worked with him.
We did a private event,
but it was,
I might've left after my spot because I went on and it was,
but then I was at college when I stopped and I'm watching him for like 15
minutes because I don't watch comics a lot.
I try not to watch too many comics because I don't want to pick up anything.
I don't want to because I'll ad Lib,
you know,
so they gotta it's gotta be,
you know what I mean?
For me to watch a comic,
uh,
you know,
Patrice,
I would always watch and I'd watch in a second,
you know,
uh,
Norton or by Mike,
but I was watching dom and I'm going,
he's one of the funniest people alive.
You can't get any fucking funnier than this guy.
He just pow,
POW,
POW.
And it's just,
and it's,
it's,
and know what it is.
It's effortless.
Well,
he's just so confident and so in a groove and as you know,
he's guy's been doing comedy 35,
50 years.
[inaudible] has a real pro to,
he's always working.
He's always writing,
always writing new stuff.
He loves comedy still.
He murdered and killed Tony when we did kill Tony Together.
He did.
This is podcast called kill Tony.
Tony Hinchcliffe and Brian Do.
And they bring on new comics every week,
like to do like one minute and dollar like an after the guy does a minute.
Uh,
the panel sits and talks to him and Donald Rare.
It's just destroying self.
He's still sharp is a fucking sword man.
He's,
he's amazing.
Regan to you ever.
She Regan Hershey's murdering it all over the French.
It's like,
no,
he's always been a killer and in the sweetest guy ever.
Fucking one of the nicest guys you'd ever want to meet.
You just want to hug him every time he see him.
Genuine,
super sweet guy.
Kish.
Fucking murderer.
Yeah,
I missed,
I missed those.
Um,
Montreal comedy festival days too.
I need to maybe book something next summer for the Montreal comedy festival.
Just for the hang we just went to do upon on.
The only reason we went and it was,
it was fun to hang out.
He comics and have club owners lie to your face.
It was a good time.
Yeah.
I'll get you back in.
Yang,
I'll get you back in and get ahold of Ms. You have a hard time selling tickets
because of like it because not having a television show because of,
here's what,
here's the thing,
I sell tickets.
You're a fucking great thank you.
Been doing comedy a long time.
We're almost out of time.
We have five minutes left.
Certain errors I shall take you shorted.
I know my problem was after last comic I was selling out everywhere.
Right,
but that audience,
what they saw me doing TV and when did they show me doing clubs are two
different things because it was a sweet telecine watered down,
watered down and now all of a sudden you're at the club.
So and plus I had a reputation as the east coast.
He's right.
So I toned it down a lot,
you know,
and less crowd work and more material and whatever.
I listen,
I do what I,
what I need to do,
but it selling certain eras,
I pack them out with something.
We'll call this movie,
who knows?
Next thing you know,
doing theaters.
Again,
it goes up and down.
But what one thing I always do is I always keep writing.
I got my four CD coming out.
I always keep fucking writing and whether I'm working a fucking beat club,
see club,
a club,
it doesn't matter to me.
I'm still doing what I fucking do.
His comedy.
That's why I like to do,
I love doing it so I don't give a fuck,
you know?
I don't know.
I fucking love comedy.
I God damn man.
I'm,
I'm looking at him.
My first honeymoon,
I did comedy.
Good for you.
I know.
We really,
yeah.
We went to San Francisco and I did a weekend at the holy cities to the club was
this fucking big school man that is an old school plays.
A lot of guys started out in that spot,
right?
Yeah.
That was like the heart of the San Francisco comedy scene.
What year was that?
I was my oldest daughter's 24 so it was about probably 25 years ago.
Ah.
I said,
I'm in San Francisco.
I might as well fucking,
yeah,
that's all.
I never got to do that place.
I got to do the old cobb's,
the old jobs and it was tiny when it was like 140 seats or something like that.
She,
this was awesome.
There's clubs that we'll use,
but it's all about like,
I had a club one said,
well,
he did too much crowd work while it was Halloween fucking weekend and they were
wearing costumes.
I'm sorry.
I'm not going to talk to the white guy in black face.
Really?
I'm not going to do 10 minutes on his care if it's crowded.
As long as it's fun.
It's funny if Sony who she cares.
Listen,
if you're selling out to club,
they don't give a fuck.
If you like the wait staff on fire,
they don't care.
All they care about is numbers.
Right.
Then again,
you'll get some a mom and pop clubs to care.
You know,
I listen,
I keep busy.
I do.
I write,
fucking got a movie fucking coming out.
Uh,
you know,
a sheet.
What the fuck?
Relax,
Bro.
I'm very like,
great.
You're fine.
It's beautiful.
I don't want to see somebody worked up.
Don't ask me about numbers aren't funny.
It's available on Tuesday the 26th.
I guarantee you your numbers are going to jump up because of this and because
of this podcast and because you need to do your own podcast.
He's going to start it soon,
right?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Need to move to La rogan.ting.com go to tank,
uh,
save yourself some money on a nice cell phone.
25 bucks,
rogan.ting.com thanks.
Also to onnit.com go to o n n I t use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any
and all supplements tomorrow.
Stefan Molyneux joins me and that should be fucking interesting.
All right.
We love the shit out of people and we'll see you soon.
Big Kiss to wall.
Wow.